Guten Abend Deutschland und guten Morgen Australien! Holt mich hier rein! Ich hab hier kein Netz, ich bin in Edge-Land.
Das berühmte Zauberwort heißt, nach, nach, nach?
Clemens Platten.
So, jetzt muss ich erstmal schön mein VPN wieder neu starten, das wird mir zum Kotzen heute. Es ist halt einfach alles schwierig.
Jetzt sag nicht Linux ist kein relevantes System.
Nein, nein, nein, Quatsch, Blödsinn. Überhaupt nicht, nein, nein. Innerhalb des Linux-Universums ist das aber jetzt... Weiß ich nicht, habe ich diesen... Gut, das ist wieder meine Perspektive. Da gibt es andere, viel bekanntere Linux-Podcasts, die jetzt wirklich eine große Rolle spielen. Also, wenn hier das überhaupt irgendwie aufgeführt ist, dann müssten da zahlreiche andere genannt werden, die ich jetzt leider nicht alle so aufzählen kann, weil die heißen immer Linux irgendwas und ich komm da total durcheinander. Aber Linux Voice ist es definitiv nicht. So, dann haben wir schöne Ecken.
Ja, super.
Schöne Grüße an Cornelis. Ja, toll und so. Sogar mit einer kompletten Episodenliste.
Vielleicht sollte man einfach mal unsere komplette Episodenliste da reinpasten. Dann wird der Artikel wenigstens richtig lang.
Genau. Software Engineering Radio, gibt es ja auch schon.
Ja, aber das ist wieder ein englischer Podcast.
Ja, der in Deutschland gemacht wird.
Der in Deutschland gemacht wird. Okay, naja, warum auch nicht?
Ja, warum auch nicht. Also den gibt es ja jetzt auch schon ziemlich lange. Ist halt schon seit 2006 dabei. Ist natürlich wirklich nochmal eine Supernische in den Nischen. Dann Soziopod, okay, der hat ja eine grimme Online-Wort bekommen. Der ist natürlich hochrelevant, gar keine Frage. Dann Sterngeschichten von Florian Freistetter, leitet weiter auf Florian Freistetter. Der dann eben auch in der Kategorie Podcast ist. Wobei ich hier unten nur Kategorie Podcast-Ter.
Ich finde das Thema ist ganz schön meta.
Ja natürlich ist das meta. Hier geht es wirklich um meta. Ich wollte das einfach mal besprochen haben. This American Life kommt dann noch? Gut, meinetwegen. Da frage ich mich natürlich, was ist mit den anderen Sachen, so Radiolab und so weiter, die so ganz unbestritten große, auch in aktuellen Diskussionen wichtige Sachen sind, die auch alle schon tausendmal gelöscht worden sind. Dann gibt es hier jetzt noch einen Podcast um 5 Uhr abends von der Internationalen Kampagne für die Menschenrechte im Iran. Also, worauf ich hinausfälle, ist, dass es einfach alles vollkommen zerklüftet. Und ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, warum, also warum.
Ja, da könnte man jetzt locker 40, 50 Podcasts reintun und dann könnte man die Hälfte von denen, die jetzt da drin sind, wieder rauswerfen, weil sie gegen den anderen 50, die man gerade erst reingeschaufelt hat, vielleicht doch nicht so relevant sind.
Ich finde, man könnte eigentlich über alle Podcasts, die irgendwie ein nennenswertes Archiv aufgebaut haben, die es lange gibt, weil wenn etwas nicht gehört wird, dann wird es auch irgendwann nicht mehr produziert und dann gibt es dann darüber auch nichts zu erzählen. Dann würde auch niemand was darüber schreiben. Aber wenn Leute da sind und dann anfangen, darüber was zu schreiben, dann füllen sich die halt auch an. Dann würde dann sozusagen auch so ein Mehrwert daraus entstehen, weil Leute das überhaupt erst mal als wichtig ansehen, da auch Informationen zusammenzutragen. Aber wenn man halt innerhalb von vier Stunden sozusagen sofort gleich dieses Schild irrelevant auf die Stirn geklebt bekommt. Also es ist ja auch diese Geschwindigkeit, die mich da so total stört. Als ob das jetzt nicht auch erst mal ein paar Wochen reifen kann, ja, so. Dann wird sich vielleicht diese Relevanz auch irgendwie ergeben. Man kann sie ja auch gerne anmahnen. Aber dass das sozusagen auch automatisch unter diesem Aspekt, das muss jetzt hier raus, dass das sozusagen das erste ist. Also wo ist sozusagen die, ja, ist ja noch ein bisschen dünne hier, gibt's ja auch alles diese ganzen Template in der Wikipedia. Da hätten wir noch gerne mehr Hintergrund, diese, also so ein bisschen so an diesen Goodwill zu appellieren oder das mehr zu so einem Hey Leute, hier gibt's richtig was zu tun. Hier fehlt Information, hier ist es irgendwie, das ist noch nicht gut. Das wäre ja ein Incentive, sich dann auch da mal drauf zu stürzen. Aber wenn es sozusagen nur darum geht mit, ja, du musst große Reichweite nachweisen, aber Zahlen sind irrelevant. Okay, was soll man denn da jetzt schreiben?
Das heißt, es muss ein BZ-Artikel geben, wo sie sagen, wir sind hier voll coolen Jungs und blauen Blubben.
Genau, so ein scheißer Artikel. Schönen finde ich den Hinweis in der Lösch-Diskussion.
Du kannst dich an den anderen Artikeln in der Kategorie Podcast orientieren. Genau, das ist so.
Also, wenn du es mal so weit gebracht hast wie der Forced-Cast, oder all die anderen Podcasts, die auch nur auf Autoren linken, dann...
Dieser Zweizeilen-Artikel, also so gesehen müsste man da noch was rausstreichen, weil der ist ja noch viel zu langartig.
Gips, gips, gips.
Na komm, jetzt haben wir über Bitcoin geredet, reden wir mal kurz über Relevanz.
Ja, aber da kann man jetzt doch so lange rumheulen, wie wir wollen.
Ich heule nicht rum. Ja, aber ich heule nicht wegen mir, ich heule wegen... Mich macht das traurig mit der Wikipedia, also speziell mit der deutschen. Ich finde das einfach super schade, weil einfach die Nützlichkeit dieses Mediums, die ist künstlich reduziert.
Meinst du, es könnte alles viel besser sein?
Was heißt das könnte? Es ist viel besser in der englischen Wikipedia. Die englische Wikipedia hat einen ganz anderen Inklusionsansatz. Da hast du einfach sehr, sehr oft zu einem Subbegriff einfach einen eigenen Artikel. Der steht erstmal für sich und damit gibt es auch einen Ort, wo man seine Gedanken versammeln kann. Wenn jetzt Freak Show unter Metaebene oder meinem Namen oder was auch immer einsortiert ist und dann nur so ein Nebensatz vielleicht ein Abschnitt ist, dann fängst du doch nicht an, diesen Abschnitt auszubauen mit kulturellen Erkenntnissen über dieses Ding. Das machst du in seinem eigenen Artikel. Vom Speicherplatz ist das dasselbe. Es ist sozusagen nur so dieser Kampf um die eigene URL. Aber in dem Moment, wo du das halt auch auslagerst und sagst, das ist, das kann ja niemand bestreiten, dass die Freak Show zum Beispiel ein eigenes Ding ist. Man es existiert. Es ist existiert lange. Es hat eine URL, es hat eine Homepage, es hat eine Präsenz. Es ist nicht bei Facebook.
Ich mach das erst seit acht Jahren.
Das ist halt noch nix.
Wir haben auch erst den zweiten Namen.
Ja, aber weißt du, was ich meine? Man kann ja nicht vorbeidiskutieren, dass das eine Sichtbarkeit und eine Erkennbarkeit gegeben ist und sich das auch selber aktiv dokumentiert. Also es ist auch nicht irgendwas unklar oder so. Sondern es lässt sich alles an sich selber verhältnismäßig gut verifizieren. Klar, natürlich kann ich ja alles schreiben im Internet, aber da gibt es genug Leute.
Da sind halt ein paar Leute, die das anders sehen. Da kann man halt das doof finden, aber da hab ich halt auch gar keinen Einfluss. Und ja, dann lohnt es sich nicht so richtig, sich da...
Ja, das ist aber genau das Problem.
Was, ich?
Na, dann lass Leute halt sagen, ich hab da keinen Einfluss, da kann ich ja nix machen, dann geh ich weg. Wikipedia beklagt, dass sie sozusagen keine neuen Autoren mehr finden. Die haben...
Sind die alle so vergraulen?
Naja, eben.
Ja, aber was ist jetzt unser Einfluss?
Was jetzt unser konkreter Einfluss ist, kann ich dir nicht sagen. Wir reden jetzt darüber, Leute hören uns zu, werden sich ihre eigenen Gedanken machen, vielleicht kluge Kommentare in den Chat oder in die Kommentare reinwerfen. Das muss man dann sehen, aber ich finde, man muss diese Debatte auch machen.
Oder Jungs, ihr könnt ja den Artikel erweitern, weil, wie viel Sendung hatten wir? 170, ja, die könnte man ja schon erwähnen. Unsere 170 Sendung könnte man in dem Artikel ja auch auflisten oder irgendwie so. Man kann ja da einen ordentlichen Artikel draus machen.
Ja, aber das finde ich zum Beispiel irrelevant. Also ich fände das sehr...
Die Sendung an sich?
Ja genau, ich finde, also gute Artikel über jetzt Podcasts oder Blogs, also über solche Netzmedien, ein guter Artikel wäre sozusagen, was ist unser Ansatz, was ist unser Community-Konzept, was macht es sozusagen aus, was ist der Charakter davon? Was baut sich da für eine Community drum herum? Ich meine, wir wissen alle, dass das hier mit unserer Community... Wir können jetzt auch noch mal hier auf das Bingo hinweisen. Ich finde, das ist ein sehr guter Punkt, dass man hier, wenn man sich das so anbaut, wie sich hier einfach immer wieder so munter was entwickelt. Hier ist ein Dialog am Start, hier sind Leute kreativ, hier entstehen halt Sachen. Das ist ja jetzt nicht nichts. Also ich glaube, der Forced-Cast ist da noch nicht so weit.
Meinst du nicht, dass der eine große Community hat? Das Forced-Cast-Bingo? Guck mal nach! Da ist bestimmt die Eule in der Mitte.
Ja, aber ganz unabhängig von der Freak Show, da gibt es halt auch noch 200, 300 andere solche Sachen. Und ich finde, das muss halt auch dokumentiert werden. Also ich finde, in gewisser Hinsicht ist sogar die Wikipedia in der Pflicht, solche Sachen zu dokumentieren. Weil ich will das nachschlagen. Ich finde es gut, dass der Forced-Cast da beschrieben ist, weil ich weiß jetzt mit einem Klick, wer das macht, seit wann es das gibt, wer die Menschen dahinter sind und so weiter. Das finde ich einfach eine relevante Information. Das stillt einfach mein Recherche-Bedürfnis. Aber wenn ich immer wieder an diese Verkürzungen und redirecten auf anderen Scheiß, wo das dann vielleicht noch nicht mal mehr erwähnt ist, weil es auch schon wieder rausgelöscht wurde, das ist halt irgendwie blöd. Es gibt keine Ansatzpunkte, selber was zu entwickeln und beizutragen. Und dieser schöne Ursprungs-Slogan, also was ich immer wieder geil finde, ist hier, als die, wiederhole ich mich da wahrscheinlich, als die, glaube ich, die französische Wikipedia ihren zehntausendsten Artikel hatte, da war die Deutsche irgendwie schon so bei 100.000 oder so, dann haben die das irgendwie gefeiert, also den Meilenstein und sie haben das getan unter dem Titel Eine Birne ist eine Frucht. Und nämlich, eine Birne ist eine Frucht, war der erste Satz des französischen Artikels über Birnen. Das hat halt da jemand reingeschrieben. Birne gab es nicht. Klick, Seite angelegt. Eine Birne ist eine Frucht, safe.
Das war der zehntausendste Artikel.
Nein, das war nicht der zehntausendste Artikel, sondern das war, wie dieser konkrete Artikel seinerzeit begonnen hat. Andere Leute stoßen auf Birne und sagen, naja, das kann man aber auch ein bisschen genauer erklären. Und dann macht's bam, bam, bam, bam, bam. Und wenn du heute auf Birne in der französischen Wikipedia gehst, dann steht da das, was man eben so erwartet, was da so stehen dürfte. Birne, Klassifikation, bla, Chemie, Biologie, Kultur, alles Mögliche. Ja, so. Aber es muss halt irgendwo anfangen. Es muss halt irgendwie auch starten dürfen. Und das ist irgendwie weg. Dieses starten dürfen, dieses mitnehmen und so. Was wir auch hier bei unserer Diskussion über den Kongress hatten. Dieses Leute begleiten und Freiraum geben, die neu sind. Den so ein Einfallstor zu geben, die irgendwie auch an der Hand zu nehmen. Aber wenn du bei Wikipedia irgendwie Raum reinkommst und sagst, ich würde gern was schreiben. Also total irrelevant. Du kennst ja unsere ehe einen Regeln seit tausend Jahren nicht. Und jetzt hast du irgendwie das Komma an der falschen Stelle gesetzt. Geh bitte raus. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen sehr übertrieben. Ich weiß aber.
Nur ein bisschen.
Wirken tut es dann halt so. Und dann denken die Leute so, pfff, pisser. Dann geh ich doch woanders hin.
Nee, man kann eben nicht woanders hingehen.
Doch, klar. Ich meine, du musst ja deine Energie nicht in Wikipedia geben.
Die hören dann auf. Die können nicht woanders ihren Artikel anlegen.
Die starten dann Podcasts.
Das ist ein Durchbetext.
Darauf läuft es hinaus.
Ich würde mir jetzt die Wikipedia hier für irrelevant erklären und würde mal mit dem nächsten Thema weitermachen.
Wikipedia ist aber nicht irrelevant. Wikipedia ist scheiße wichtig. Und deswegen... Also, I care. I care about Wikipedia.
Dann mach doch du da mit und sag den hier doch, ist aber relevant.
Du, ich hab...
Haben sie dich rausgeschmissen?
Nee, ich hab tausende Edits in der Wikipedia. Ich muss mir da nichts vorwerfen lassen. Meistens sind es zwar schon lange her und das war auch noch so zu frühen Zeiten. Aber ich hab meinen Beitrag zum Weltkulturerbe durchaus geleistet. Der ist sicherlich noch überdurchschnittlich. Dann reden wir nicht mehr über Wikipedia. Aber wir können ja über Podcasts reden.
Haben wir schon lange nicht mehr gemacht. Oder?
Oder wollen wir lieber wegreden? Ich möchte gar nicht über einen Podcast.
Reden.
Aber es sind nur so ein paar Kleinigkeiten passiert. Soll ich oder habt ihr einen anderen Vorschlag?
Wie du willst.
Wie ich will.
Ja, mach doch einfach.
Wir waren ja gerade schon bei Podcasts. Willst du eine kleine Zwischenpause oder willst du mit Podcasts gleich weitermachen?
Na ich könnte über diese Neues aus dem Welt der Kapitel marken.
Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen ein Podcast-Thema. Deswegen würde ich jetzt vorschlagen, wir machen eine kurze Werbepause und dann machst du mit Podcast weiter. Dann kannst du kurz noch mal Energie sammeln.
Ist das gut, dann hole ich mir ein Bier und du fängst schon mal mit der Werbepause an.
Ich habe mir nämlich hier…
Wir haben ja aber gar keinen Jingle dafür.
Ich habe mir kurz zum Jahresende ein neues Gadget geleistet. Es geht auch ganz schnell, ist alles gar nicht so schlimm. Ich habe mir einen Bluetooth-Lautsprecher geholt. Ich werde jetzt mal den Firmennamen sagen, was ich eigentlich immer nicht so cool finde, aber man kann ja auch von Produkten schlecht erzählen, wenn man das nicht tut. Das ist ein Bose SoundLink Mini. Es ist so ein kleiner, relativ stabiler Kasten. Mit so einem dicken Alurahmen fühlt es sich heftig an. Gewichtsmäßig, ich mag das ja sehr, wenn Sachen noch mal ein bisschen schwer und stabil sind. Der ist echt so, wenn der runterfällt, dann willst du deinen Fuß wegziehen, weil du sonst Angst unter deinem Fuß hast. Und ich finde das gut. Der geht auch nicht so schnell mal kaputt, wenn man es drauffallen sollte oder sonst wo, weil es halt eben kein Plastik was springt, sondern es ist, glaube ich, ein richtig stabiler Alurahmen. Und wie gesagt, Bluetooth-Lautsprecher, man kann den mit seinem iPhone perren oder mit seinem Rechner oder mit was auch immer mit Bluetooth. Man kann aber auch direkt ein Kabel reinstecken. Also Klinke, dreieinhalb Zoll. Dreieinhalb Zoll? Nee, was sagt man? Dreieinhalb Millimeter sind das, ne?
1.3,5 Zoll wäre ein bisschen hoch.
Bisschen heftig.
Ja, sieht zumindest mal gut aus.
Man lädt dann auch über USB den Akku auf, da sind zweimal 18 650 Batterien drin. Die kann man auch, ich hab schon, ich mag das sehr gerne. Das Ding hat so ca. 10 Stunden, sagen sie, oder vielleicht ein paar mehr. Wie lange es hält, so bei voller Lautstärke. Kommen wir gleich zu. Und man kann natürlich die Batterien, das sind jetzt nicht die fettesten 18 650 Batterien da drin, die es so gibt. Da sind welche mit 2200 mAh drin. Man könnte sich welche von Panasonic mit 3400 mAh holen, das da einbauen und die Leistung von dem Ding nochmal um 50% oder die Laufzeit verlängern.
Und sicher ist der Laderegler die auch geladen kriegt?
Ja, wieso nicht? Das ist dann nur mehr Ampere, man muss nur länger laden, man muss ja nicht mehr laden. Also das sollte einfach nur ein bisschen länger dauern, bis die voll sind.
Und über einen Backchannel erfahre ich von einem gewissen Mitpodcaster, dass er das Teil auch gut findet.
Ja, ich hab den schon.
Und was für ein Mitpodcaster, der immer sich während der Sendung meldet, obwohl er sich vorher abgemeldet hat und dann das Gefühl gehabt hätte er doch Zeit.
Ja, welcher sollte es wohl sein, wenn er sich während der Sendung zwischendrin meldet.
Ich hab schon auf dem Camp hatten wir ein so ein Ding in unserem, wir machen ja da ein bisschen Büro sozusagen, unser Hinterzimmer nennen wir das, und da hatte schon einer von den Kassenleuten sowas und hat das mal angeschmissen. Und ich war eigentlich bisher Bluetooth, war ich immer noch nicht so richtig überzeugt. Und hab das da aber gesehen und das hat funktioniert. Und das Ding hat wirklich ordentlich Bums und mir hat es wirklich auch von Haptik gefallen, weil es wirklich einen vertigen, schweren Eindruck macht. Und das hat mir sehr gefallen. Es ist jetzt auch noch mal ein bisschen billiger geworden. Und dann habe ich mir den mal geleistet.
Was heißt denn bitte ich, was kostet denn das Teil?
Na im Sommer hat es noch 200 gekostet, jetzt kostet es 170. Das ist schon ein ordentlicher Preis, aber ich kann ja mal reinhauen kurz, ja.
Macht der Sound in beide Richtungen?
Nee, ich glaube eine Seite ist Hochtöner und die andere Seite ist Tieftöner. Ich glaube Tieftöner geht nach hinten raus, weil man den ja eh nicht orten kann. Ich hau jetzt mal rein hier, aktuell ein bisschen spät, aber ich finde den ja immer wieder gut. Und das müsste jetzt bei dir da ordentlich rauskommen. Der kann bumm. Das ist ja eine tolle Lautstärke.
Dann muss ich mal kurz den Kopfhörer absetzen.
Oh je, hier ist Stimmung ey.
Für so ein kleines Ding ist das schon ordentlich. Ich dreh mal wieder ein bisschen runter.
Na gut, ich mein, David Bowie geht ja immer.
David Bowie geht immer, auf jeden Fall. Ich mach das auch mal aus.
Ja. Man habe dich seelig.
Was das Ding noch hat, ist Quatschen mit einem. Also hast du ja gerade gehört, beim Ein- und Ausschalten. Quatschen mit einem? Ja, hier. Wie kam das an bei euch?
So ein Text-to-Speech-Voice.
Genau, also er sagt. Wie mein Telefon heißt. Das finde ich schon beeindruckend, dass Geräte mit einem Quatschen, das finde ich schon ganz witzig. Ich glaube, Software-Updates kann man dafür auch machen. Man muss seine Boxen mit Firmware-Updates versorgen, gab es auch schon eins oder mehrere sogar. Hat es noch irgendwelche speziellen Features? Ich glaube, man kann auch damit das Ding als Freisprecheinrichtung benutzen. Müsste also auch irgendwo ein Mikro haben. Das habe ich aber noch nicht so richtig probiert. Als ich letztes Mal angerufen wurde, kam das dann auf diesem Ding und das ging nicht so richtig. Da musste ich dann erstmal auflegen und nochmal irgendwie umschalten und nochmal rangehen.
Also der Mensch, den wir jetzt nicht erwähnen, sagt einerseits, man kann das an mehrere Geräte binden.
Der ruft jetzt auch noch an.
Damit das Ding geklingelt, aber ich habe es schon längst ausgemacht.
Er meint, das sei dann lustig. Was auch immer dann lustig sei. Mach doch, das ist doch dieser Mensch, der immer gerne anruft, wenn er nicht da ist. Ohne uns kannst du doch auch nicht, Clemens. Du brauchst das doch auch.
Man kann den Bose Sounding-Meer auch mit mehreren Bluetooth-Geräten linken. Ich glaube, er merkt sich immer die letzten beiden. Das heißt, wenn ich das Ding einschalte, dann connectet er sich auch automatisch mit meinem Telefon und ich muss gar nichts weiter machen.
Er merkt sich nur zwei?
Dazu den er sich dann auch live connectet. Das heißt, da können zwei so mehr oder weniger nicht gleichzeitig abspielen, aber wenn die abspielen, dann müssen die auch nichts machen, sondern spielen ab und andere merkt er sich aber auch, aber die sind nicht live aktiv. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das genau erklären soll. So sagen die das.
Also man kann ja connected sein.
Das heißt, mein Telefon kann mit dem connected sein und deins auch und wenn ich aufhören zu spielen und du startest, dann bist du auch dran und du musst dich nicht neu connecten.
Connected oder paired? Das ist jetzt ein Unterschied.
Connected und gepaert kann er glaube ich 10 oder 50.
Das probieren wir jetzt nochmal aus. Dann würde ich auch mal wissen, was passiert. Weil das ist nämlich immer so das Problem.
Ja, das ist auch nicht so einfach. Also ich hab halt eben mein Telefon, mein Laptop und zu Hause mein Desktop. Das sind halt schon drei und dann schmeißt er halt immer einen raus, ja.
Okay, also er meint wirklich, dass man mit zwei sich ja connecten kann? Dann machen wir das mal.
Der ist jetzt mit meinem connected und jetzt mach ich mal hier pairing an, damit du auch kannst. Dann müsstest du den jetzt sehen.
Tue ich auch.
Und dann will Clemens uns anrufen, aber Clemens muss halt noch mal ein paar Sekunden warten, weil wir jetzt erstmal das eine testen.
Ich bin jetzt wirklich verbunden. Oh Gott, das redet dann die ganze Zeit in dieser Text-to-Speech-Voice.
Kann man abstellen natürlich.
Das ist gut, muss man auch.
Ja, nee manchmal, aber es ist cool, wenn man einschaltet und dann sagt, wie voll er noch ist, das ist schon auch cool. Und diese Kontakte auf der Unterseite, die dir Roddi schon bemerkt hat, was der geneigte Hörer, Bingo, nicht sieht, es gibt natürlich auch eine Ladeschale, wo man das Ding einfach nur drauf stellt und dann lädt es sich auf.
Jetzt bricht er die Telefonnummer, das ist alles on record.
Tja, da musst du ja dazwischen reden, damit man es sich hört.
Jetzt hat er aufgelegt, was denn du?
Ich weiß auch nicht, was er will. Ich spiele jetzt erstmal was ab und dann will ich mal sehen, was das Teil tut, wenn du auch abspielst.
Auch geht nicht, sondern dann danach, ohne zu aktivieren. Spielst du ja was ab? Ich höre nichts.
Angeblich. Angeblich spiele ich gerade was ab.
Ja, hier.
Ja, ich spiele jetzt was ab. So, und wenn du jetzt auch was abspielst, bricht dann meine Verbindung in dem Moment ab, ist das sozusagen Last Man Standing.
So, meins kommt jetzt nicht.
Wie kommt nicht?
Naja, der spielt das jetzt nicht ab, weil deins läuft. Wenn du aber jetzt Stopp drückst.
Was heißt das, er spielt es nicht ab?
Na, man kann es hier sehen, es wird hingesendet, aber anscheinend von dem Gerät ignoriert. Also mein Telefon denkt jetzt, es spielt ab.
Vielleicht hast du es nicht laut.
Aber das ist doch total blöd. Lass es mal so laufen. Jetzt beende ich mal, also mach Pause hier. Und dann kommst du automatisch durch.
Genau, dann nimmt er den anderen.
Und wenn ich jetzt wieder spiele?
Nee, dann hast du Pech gehabt. Wenn du jetzt spielst, musst du warten, bis ich Stopp drücke oder auflege. Oder weißt schon.
Das heißt, es gibt keine Rückmeldung darüber.
Genau, ich mach das jetzt mal.
Ob es auch wirklich ankommt und er mixt auch nicht, weil das wäre jetzt sozusagen noch eine Option gewesen.
Aber ist das cool mixen?
Ich meine, connected heißt für mich... Connected. Vielleicht ist das ja auch das, was man mal will.
Ja, könnten sie vielleicht mit einem Software-Update hin drehen, aber ich finde es erstmal so, ich muss da nicht alles Mögliche, verschiedene gleichzeitig haben. Was noch cool ist, ich hatte das vorher auch nicht, ist, dass auf dem iPhone und auf dem Android ist es auch so, oben im Menü neben der Batterie erscheint noch eine Batterie und die zeigt dir den Akkustand vor diesem Ding an.
Ach.
Hier, da oben in der Ecke siehst du diese zweite Batterie neben dem Bluetooth-Zeichner, diese Hochkant-Batterie.
Seit wann gibt es das denn?
Oder auch, du kannst das machen und dann steht es hier.
So wie mit dem neuen Akkupack und so weiter.
Das ist ein Bluetooth-Standard-Feature, genau.
Genau, das heißt, auch wenn du andere Sachen, wenn du eine Bluetooth-Tastatur gepaart hast, dann zeigt der das ja auch an. Das heißt, es verhält sich da protokollkonform und zeigt den Akkustand mit an. Das ist ja ganz nice. Ja, das wird langsam was mit dem blauen Zahn.
Den Korn wartet man zehn Jahre.
Gibt es hier noch Features?
Ich meine, das ist jetzt ein Bose-Gerät. Kann der auch Noise-Canceling?
Kann er nicht. Noise-Canceling kommen wir dann in der nächsten Sendung, weil ich habe noch Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer von der Konkurrenzfirma von Bose, nämlich Sandpyser. Wenn wir die schon mal gegenseitig ausspielen müssen, habe ich aber nicht bei.
Du hast ja, Clemens meint, gerade das Gerät liest da nämlich auch den Namen aus dem Adressbuch vor. Du hast ihn aber nicht im Adressbuch. Das habe ich gerade gesehen.
Kann sein, ja genau, habe ich nicht.
Jetzt packst du ihn mal in dein Adressbuch mit irgendeinem ulkigen...
Du bist noch gepaart, er kann auch dich anrufen.
Ja, aber dann kommt auch kein ulkiger Name, sondern der richtige, der da drin steht. Hättest du jetzt irgendwie Hans Wurst eingeben können und...
Ja, kannst du ja auch machen.
Ich erinnere doch jetzt hier nicht meinen Fuh.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das mit dem Mikrofon klappt, also...
Ich weiß nicht, wie schnell die das denn sind.
Soll ich das mal ein bisschen an mein Mikro halten?
Er könnte ja den Nickname vorlesen, das macht er wahrscheinlich nicht, ne?
Weiß ich nicht, ich hab das noch nie probiert, was der da vorleset.
Das werden wir jetzt gleich sehen, was er vorleset. Wenn es ein Nickname gibt, ob er den nimmt, macht er wahrscheinlich nicht. Da dauert das wieder Stunden. Ah, da kommt er schon.
Shrimpy!
Ist das jetzt das Gerät, was das vorgelesen hat, oder hat dein Telefon das jetzt als Audio dahingesendet?
Das ist wirklich eine gute Frage, aber das war ja die Voice, die es auch sonst macht, und die Voice kommt ja nicht aus deinem Telefon.
Das ist schon krass, was die hier einbauen, oder?
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen eine Bluetooth. Ich bin auch dein Kopfhörer und dein Call-Control-Dingsbums, und dann hat er wahrscheinlich den Text bekommen. Und setzt das dann halt auch entsprechend um. Also ich nehme an, der nimmt einfach den Stringen sozusagen aus dieser Information heraus.
Ja, aber spannend wäre jetzt gewesen, wenn auch du rangegangen wärst und ob das mit dem Mikro dann auch klappt.
Hatst du denn ein Mikrofon?
Ja, angeblich ja, sonst würde es ja keinen Sinn machen, den hier zu hören, oder? Du meinst, du hast das Mikrofon im Telefon, aber der audio-komponieren...
Man muss ja nicht gleich mit jedem reden, der einen anruft. Ich gehe ja meistens noch nicht mal ran.
Gut. Jetzt müssen wir nochmal austesten. Ich habe das noch nicht richtig getestet. Jedenfalls, was ich noch sagen wollte, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt durchgekommen ist, aber das hat noch hier so vier Kontakte auf der Unterseite. Da wird eine Ladeschale mit zugeliefert. Das heißt, man kann es einfach immer in so eine Ladeschale stellen oder auf sie drauf stellen. Und dann lädt es da drüber, ohne dass man da Kabel stecken muss. Also es ist jetzt nicht hier so im Induktionsladung, sondern mit Kontakten auf der Unterseite, aber es kommt der Sache schon sehr nahe.
So, ich muss mal hier den Hanswurst wieder rausnehmen, weil die anderen, die weiß es, die Apple Watch, die frisst das halt sofort. Jetzt steht da mal Hanswurst, muss ja auch nicht sein. Muss ja auch nicht sein, ne? Ach ja. So, ihr wisst ja, ihr ruft die Nummer neben der Landesflagge an. Nein, ihr wollt das jetzt alle kaufen. Ihr wollt das alle kaufen. Ihr habt genug Geld auf dem Konto. Es ist egal, ob ihr genug Geld auf dem Konto habt.
Verkauft einfach eure Bitcoins.
Klicken Sie jetzt den Link in den Show Notes. Und machen Sie die Podcasts da reich.
Das braucht weniger als einen Bitcoin. Einen halben eigentlich.
Also eigentlich würde man für einen Bitcoin zwei Schnäppchen davon kriegen.
Schnäppchen, nur ein halber Bitcoin.
Genau, also ich werde da so einen kapitalistischen Mach mich reich Link generieren. Und dann werden einfach die Reste, die jetzt nach Weihnachten übrig geblieben sind, in den Regalen, die werden jetzt einfach mal abgeräumt. Ich gucke nochmal, was hier so der Preis ist. Mini 2 heißt er, ne?
Genau, es gab vorher noch den normalen Mini, aber das ist die Ablösung davon. Da hat Bose nochmal nachgelegt.
970. Gibt es übrigens auch?
In weiß.
In weiß? Und ich sehe hier auch gerade, es gibt für dieses Produkt ein Third-Party-Add-On.
Echt?
Und zwar ein Walnuss-Echtholz-Cover.
Das habe ich noch nicht gesehen, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall ganz viele Covers und Bumpers und Taschen und Zeug und so.
Walnuss... Bitte habe ich irgendwas verpasst. Es gibt Taschen dafür.
Und Vamper.
Von anderen Herstellern. Oh, die Tasche ist aber geil. Wow, das ist ja hier schon ein...
Du meinst die mit den Noppen?
Ja.
Weil du willst das Ding ja auch schon, weiß nicht, wenn du im Park eine kleine Versammlung Partymaster bist. Das Ding ist schon cool.
Die Cover sieht geil aus.
Also ich meine, als Lautsprecherhersteller hast du es ja geschafft. Wenn Third Partys Cover für deinen Lautsprecher herstellen, dann hast du es wirklich geschafft.
Absolut, das ist geil. Das ist ja auch so eine merkwürdige... Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wo das herkommt. Ich muss auch zugeben, ich bin da auch selber schuldig. Ich hab ja früher so als... Ich hab ja früher, wie so ein Bekloppter, also früher erst in den 80ern, da hatte ich ja mal so eine Phase, wie den ja heute auch so einige haben. Man ist halt so in IT, ist total cool, und verdient einfach absurde Mengen Geld, weil es gibt da kaum andere, und es war immer alles chronisch überbezahlt. Weil man konnte ja irgendwie einen Computer einschalten und korrekt wieder herunterfahren, und damit war man ja schon irgendwie in der Top 1%. Also ich habe ja sozusagen für meine Verhältnisse und auch vor allem für die Verhältnisse anderer Leute in so einer Phase immer unglaublich viel Geld verdient, was natürlich mir am Ende nichts gebracht hat, weil ich natürlich nicht damit umgehen konnte. Was hätte man alles machen können? Gut, Bitcoins gab es noch nicht, aber Apple-Aktien wären zum Beispiel geil gewesen. Hätte ich das nicht alles in Hifi-Anlagen versenken sollen, dann wäre es das gewesen. Aber wer weiß sowas halt schon. Stattdessen habe ich mich irgendwie bei Sony durchgetankt.
Mit den Holzwangen, ich weiß, habe ich auch gemacht.
Und dann diese Holzwangen, und ich weiß nicht, warum das so geil aussah, aber irgendwie...
Ich habe die immer noch zu Hause.
Lautsprecher, schwarz und dazu irgendwie diese... Ja, ich auch. Haben wir nicht sogar dieselbe Serie?
Ja, so ein bisschen. Du hast dir die digitalen Dingsversionen geholt, die auch jetzt noch im Club stehen unten. Und ich habe das gleich in dieser Minimal-Version, die so nach... Nee, der steht da noch. Auch nicht mehr lange, weil dann hole ich mir den irgendwann.
Ja, ich überlege jetzt, ob ich den nicht vielleicht... Ja, für den Sohn ist das geil.
Ja, wenn er darum spielen mag, aber ich glaube, der...
Na so alt mit du. Der wollte neulich ein Kassetten-Abspielgerät haben. Moment, da muss ich erst mal hier wieder reaktivieren. Aber ich hab den ganzen Stabler jetzt noch stehen.
Ich hab den auch stehen, aber ich hab...
Die Idee bin ich ja noch gar nicht gekommen.
Vorstufe und Endstufe am Start, den Rest nicht mehr.
Ja, weil das ist ja so total retro. Ich hab hier sogar noch einen Plattenspieler hier stehen, weil mir jemand mal eine Schallplatte geschenkt hat. Da hab ich einen Plattenspieler noch mit dazu. Was man auch abspielen kann. Und das ist aber für die Kids geil.
Ja, aber du warst jetzt bei früher und hast absurd viel Geld verdient und dann wolltest du eigentlich was anderes erzählen können.
Naja, dann hab ich halt dieses ganze HiFi-Equipment immer gekauft für teuer Geld. So Kassetten, Abspielgeräte für... Ich will die Zahlen gar nicht sagen, aber du weißt es wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ich weiß, was die Teile gekostet haben.
Das war teuer alles. Ja, da ging es dann hin, die gute Kohle, anstatt irgendwie mal für die Zukunft.
Bei mir war das so eine Ausbildung, noch bei Mama gewohnt und alle zwei Monate das Ausbildungsgeld voll zusammengespart und dann immer einen Teil geholt und nach so einem Jahr oder so hatte ich alle die Haife-Anlage zusammen. Und ich hab die heute noch. Also okay, ich brauch sie nicht mehr, aber alles ist noch da.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es hier einen Walnuss-Echtholzkover für das Soundlink Mini 2. Ich bin begeistert.
Man muss jetzt aber noch dazu sagen, weil als ich das auf dem Kongress so ausgepackt hab, dann kamen natürlich auch andere Leute, die auch Audio-Lautsprecher haben. Und einer zum Beispiel hatte so ein rundes Teil, sah so ein bisschen aus wie der Apple-Müll-Eimer. Also hier dieser Mac Pro. Nur das ist halt ein Lautsprecher. Weil ich weiß jetzt leider nicht von welcher Firma. Aber er meinte, man kann da zwei von kaufen und kann dann sagen, hier Jungs, macht mal Stereo und dann machen die das. Die machen das so untereinander. Die fahren dann nochmal ein eigenes Netz untereinander und sorgen dann für Stereo-Sound. Das kann dieses Ding leider nicht. Das finde ich schon so ein bisschen schade.
So etwas empfehlen wir.
Wäre schon cool, weil die machen wirklich guten Bums, aber wenn man dann noch Stereo-Bums hätte.
Kannst du mir nochmal sagen, welches Gerät das tut?
Dieses andere, dann weiß ich leider nicht. Ich weiß nur, dass es so rundlich war, mit so einem Stoff bezogen von außen. JBL vielleicht? War das von JBL? Was gibt es noch für Firmennamen? Sonos Play 1 schreibt da einer.
Das würde mich jetzt noch nicht mal wundern.
Ja, könnte schon sein. Ich weiß nicht mehr so genau. Das ist mir noch ein bisschen unklar.
Da gibt es auch so Plastischlüpfer dafür und alles Mögliche.
Ich sag ja. Du hast es geschafft, wenn jemand cases für deinen Lautsprecher baut.
Also es gibt auch Originaltaschen von Bose selber. Aber das mit dem Stereo finde ich ja cool, weil da hast du dann zwei solche Teile, stellst sie irgendwo hin und es ist natürlich interessant, wie machen die das mit dem Timing?
Es ist dieser Boom, UE Boom.
Weil die müssen ja richtig, was ist der Boom bitte?
Weiß ich nicht so genau.
Ultimate Ears Boom heißt das Teil. Welches hatte ich irgendwann mal in der Hand?
Von Sonnars oder nicht von Sonnars?
Nee, von Ultimate Ears.
Dann nehm ich Sonnars mal raus.
Naja, der ist das, weiß ich nicht, ob es der ist.
Ja doch, das ist der.
Ich hatte den mal in der Hand und dachte mir nur so, wie viel Geld wollt ihr dafür haben?
UE Boom, so heißt der.
UE Boom? Das ist auch nochmal ein Link in unser Ding.
Ue Boom sozusagen.
Ue Boom macht den meisten.
Was ist denn das, Webseite mit diesem Bild? So jetzt hier. Ja, das ist das Ding. Tragbarer Bluetooth-Lautsprecher, 360°-Sound, Spritzwassergeschützt, 15 Meter kabelose Reichweite, in Schwarz, 200 Euro auch das Teil. Genau, und davon kann man aber halt eben zwei holen, wenn man möchte. Genau. Braucht man aber irgendwie so eine extra App, die das dann irgendwie managt.
Wo ist jetzt der Link, Entschuldigung?
So, warte.
Hier ist nur was mit JBL. Achso, da dieses Sonnensding oder was?
Und diesen Bose, den gibt es ja, das ist ja der Soundlink Mini. Ich glaube, die haben auch noch den normalen Soundlink. Dann ist da so ein riesengroßer Kasten und kostet 400 Euro. Aber den habe ich mir gar nicht so weiter angeguckt. Aber das hier ist halt die kleine Version und darum geht es ja auch so ein bisschen, dass man den halt mal, keine Ahnung, mit in den Garten, mit in den Park, mit in sonst wo irgendwie mitschleppen kann. Theoretisch kann man damit Fahrrad fahren und macht den einfach hinten unter den Gepäckträger und lässt ihn laufen.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, hier hast du ja schon mit 79 Euro hast du sozusagen, also zahlst fast dasselbe. Aber hast dann das Stereo, bei diesem JBL, Flip 2, tralala.
Musst du dann aber auch mal in den Chat schmeißen, weil sonst weiß ich auch nicht, was das ist.
Aber wo steht denn das hier mit diesem Stereo-Tings? Müsste das hier irgendwo stehen? Bist du sicher, dass das Ding das ist?
Nee, der UE Boom ist der, der Stereo kann.
Also was jetzt? Du hast doch gerade so einen Flip.
Nee, ich habe geraten, ob es JBL war, aber es ist dieser UE.
Aber der JBL, der hat aber eine blaue Leuchtdiode, das geht nicht.
Nee, das geht wirklich nicht.
Was? Nee, das geht nicht.
Also der Bose hat das auch, aber nur wenn man das Bluetooth auf, und das ist ja Bluetooth, wenn man das Bluetooth auf Pairing stellt, dann wird die LED blau. Wenn man fertig ist, geht es ja auch wieder auf weiß zurück. Und sie ist auch nicht so knallig blau, sondern sie ist wirklich nur so ein ganz entspanntes Blau.
Das steht auf der eigentlichen Seite von denen, steht es drauf. Erhöhen Sie die Reichweite des Sounds, indem Sie zwei UE-Booms mithilfe der UE-Boom abkabelos miteinander verbinden.
Du brauchst wahrscheinlich nur Connection zu einem von den beiden und der schickt dann seine Daten zu dem anderen weiter, der noch weiter weg ist und dann hast du dein Stereo. Du denkst, deswegen, so meinen die das wahrscheinlich, dass du nur zu einem Reichweite haben musst und nicht zu beiden.
Ja, aber dann ist das ja nur eine Verlängerung.
Aber wenn er trotzdem Stereo abspielt, ist ja okay dann.
Ja, aber wenn jeder für sich Stereo macht, aber macht nicht dann ein Stereo-Signal. Also ist nicht so, dass er mit dem zweiten den linken Kanal auf, den einen und den rechten Kanal auf den anderen verdings. Der verlängert nur das Stereo-Signal und aus dem anderen kommt genau das Deiche raus.
Aber wäre ja auch nicht schwer dann für die Software irgendwie, dass der eine nur den einen Kanal und der andere nur den anderen Kanal spielt, oder?
Im Prinzip ist die Synchronisationsaufgabe dieselbe. Aber ich weiß nicht, aber ich lese halt hier irgendwie nichts davon.
Also für den UE Boom gibt es aber auch eine ganze Menge Taschen.
Aber ich muss sagen, die Walnussholz-Nummer, soll ich das Ding gleich in meine Wunschliste setzen? Vielleicht hat ja wer Langeweile.
Das ist ja mal eine gute Idee.
Sounding mini Schwarz.
Das ist wieder so ein Feature. Manchmal ist es ja so, Hersteller kommen mit irgendwas auf den Markt, erwähnen irgendwie grob irgendein Feature und alle nörd so, was, das kann das, dann funktioniert das bestimmt so. Und stellen dann irgendwann fest so und dann ist es gar nicht so. Wie zum Beispiel als das erste schwarze MacBook damals noch Powerbook rauskam, wo der Apfel drauf war, wo er noch falsch rum war. Also erstmal war er falsch rum und weißt du noch, was die andere Diskussion war? Der leuchtet, der leuchtet! Also was, ist es wirklich wahr, der leuchtet? Und er leuchtete nicht. Bei Apple dürften sie wahrscheinlich dann in dem Moment wirklich so richtig so facial palmieren, so oh man, warum sind wir auf die Idee nicht selber gekommen? Und der nächste leuchtete dann erst. Aber es war sozusagen so sofort die Reaktion von allen so, ha, stell dir vor er leuchtet! Und ich so, Gott, das haben wir nicht gemacht, warum haben wir das nicht gemacht, so einfach.
Und du meinst jetzt ärgert sich Bose, dass sie diese Walnussschale nicht angeboten haben?
Ich will so, was du kannst zwei machen und dann ist es dann Stereo. So, das ist doch unsere erste Erwartung. Da steht wahrscheinlich auf keinem dieser Webseiten drauf, dass das geht. Das ist so das erste ist, was man denkt, ist echt zwei und dann ist es richtig Stereo.
Aber gab es sich schon früher irgendwo mal, wo man dann einfach zwei geholt hat und dann hatte man... Ach doch, hier bei unserer Anlage zum Beispiel, da war es genau andersrum. Also bei meiner Endstufe, bei dieser Sony mit den Holzwangen, du änderst dich, da ist halt eine Endstufe, weiß nicht, T81 oder so hieß die, T81 ES, das war die S-Bri-Serie, nur du änderst dich nicht.
Ja genau, die S-Bri-Serie.
Genau und man hatte halt ein Gerät und einen Linksausgang, einen Rechtsausgang und dann stand da, du kannst aber auch zwei von den Geräten kaufen und dann hast du ein Gerät pro Box und damit die doppelte Leistung und so weiter und so fort. Hab ich natürlich nie gemacht, weil es war damals schon scheiße teuer. Aber da war es sozusagen, da konnte man auch zwei holen. Ja, nicht Stereo, aber...
Weil man so etwas treiben wollte. Bei HIFIR haben sie einen halt damals gemolken. Das machen sie halt jetzt irgendwie hier bei diesen Teilen.
Ja, aber ich habe mal gegoogelt, dieser T81ES, den ich da hab, der hat keine Anzeige, das ist einfach nur so ein Gerät, noch mal ein bisschen leise, laut und ansonsten muss eigentlich alles der Vorverstärker machen. Und aber der Vorgänger davon hatte noch zwei so eine Analog-Anzeigen, so wie so ein Voltmeter, also so zwei so eine Nadeln, die halt anzeigen, wie viel Watt da gerade rausgehen. Und der, den habe ich von einem, weiß nicht wann das war, von einem Jahr oder vor zweimal aber auf eBay gesehen, der ging für 1200 Euro weg. Also der von damals, 1200 Euro, das ist, selbst wenn man das eins zu eins vom Preis umrechnet, ist das mehr, als damals dafür ausgegeben wurde. Also diese geile Analogscheiße von damals, da zahlen die Leute richtig Geld dafür. Und ich habe aber leider das Gerät danach, ohne diese Nadeln. Es war ein neuer, aber ich glaube, die Leute wollten diese Anzeige haben, das fanden die halt geil und das sieht ja schon auch schick aus. Aber ja, ich habe den von danach. Aber ich habe den kalibriert und der läuft wie eine Eins und das ist alles voll toll und ich glaube, wenn er kaputt geht, dann würde ich ihn auch reparieren oder reparieren lassen, weil es ist schon irgendwie schick. Aber verbraucht wahrscheinlich Strom, wie blöd.
Ich muss sagen, also damals hatte Sony ja auch wirklich...
Genau, den habe ich in schwarz.
Also damals hatten sie das echt im Griff.
Kannst du ja auch mal in den Chat schm- Genau, den habe ich in schwarz, da unten ist er ja.
Ich habe das ja schon.
Ich habe das ja gerade.
Das ist mein Link, nicht Schwallers. Ja, es gab die so in Champagne und in Schwarz, genau. Schwarz ist ja hier auch ein Bild.
Ich glaube, da habe ich auch nur vor ein, zwei, drei Jahren ein Foto getweetet, weil ich habe irgendwo eine Anleitung gefunden, also das Service Manual von dem Ding. Und da steht drin, dass, wenn man den dann halt aufmacht, dass man da da ist irgendwo so eine Art Potentiometer, wo man halt kalibrieren kann. Da muss einer einen bestimmten Messpunkt, genau. Das ist der Vorgänger, der ging für 1200 Euro bei eBay weg vor ein, zwei Jahren.
Die Leute sehen das nicht, wenn ich hier auf die Beine... Ja, aber du darfst das nicht so...
Der Tim hat jetzt bei thevintageknob.org auf den Sony TA-N77ES verlinkt.
Und dann sagtest du?
Und dann sagte ich, was sagte ich?
Genau den hattest du auch.
Das war der Vorgänger davon. Das war der Vorgänger und der wurde bei eBay für 1200 Euro verrückt, weil er so diese schicken Anzeigen hat. Muss man sich natürlich selber angucken.
Ja und Holzwang, ne? Also immer so, einfach so, furnierte Presssparenplatten, die da irgendwie rangeklebt wurden und sofort sah das irgendwie 500 Euro wertiger aus als ohne. Und das war meine Ursprungsfrage. Warum finden wir das eigentlich so geil, wenn so Hifi-Equipment mit so Holzfurnier beklebt ist?
Ja, das fragt man sich.
Weil Holz eigentlich schon ein sehr schickes Material ist. Und da wir nur mal erst irgendwie seit, keine Ahnung, seit 150 Jahren mit Electronics zu tun haben und seit irgendwie ein paar hundert Jahren mit Metall und aber die Jahrtausende davor irgendwie mit Holz zu tun haben, hängt das wahrscheinlich noch bei uns so drin.
Sag mal, aber der macht wirklich 600 Watt?
Ja, auch weil sich das noch gut anhört, ist ja eine andere Frage. Nee, und 600 sind das gar nicht. Ich glaube, 270 waren's.
Na zumindest geht der Zeiger bis 600 Watt rüber.
Ja, ist aber auch...
Da föhntste dir aber die meisten Boxen.
Logarithmisch, oder? Oder wie sagt man?
Ja, die Anzeige, klar, aber... die ist logarithmisch. Aber wenn dir wirklich 600 Watt liefert, dann musst du aufpassen. Mit den meisten Boxen.
Ja, mit dieser ganzen Geschichte. Es gibt ja jetzt auch eine neue Auflage von...
Aber ich war ja vor ein paar Jahren auf der Funkausstellung. Und da gab es halt irgendwie noch eine Viertelhalle von diesem klassischen Hi-Fi-Zeug. Und dann gab es aber drei Hallen Utilities mit Dock-Konnektoren. Also diese ganzen Lautsprecher und dieses ganze andere Zeug und irgendwelche komischen Telefonhörer, die man ins iPhone stecken konnte und sie als externe Telefonhörer benutzen konnte und so weiter. Also das ist irgendwie das wirklich Vergangenheit, dieses klassische Hi-Fi-Zeug. Also da war irgendwie ein Stand, die hatten normale passive Boxen, alles andere war aktiv. Und dann gab es einen, die hatten einen einfachen, also einen Verstärker, wie man ihn so kennt. Auf der einen Seite Sound rein, auf der anderen Seite halt irgendwie Boxen ran. Aber das war dann auch irgendwie ein 8-Kanal oder so für so eine 7.1-Anlage. Also es ist echt irgendwie erstaunlich, dass es das einfach gar nicht mehr gibt.
Ich finde es eigentlich schon ganz cool, dass meine Anlage irgendwie, also auch dieser Vorversteiger, der kann fast nichts, hat halt seine Eingänge. Du kannst mit den Eingängen hin und her schalten. Noch ein bisschen Tiefen und Höhen kann man ein bisschen nachregeln und irgendwie Mono und Stereo einstellen. Und eine Lauten-Taste hat es glaube ich schon nicht mal mehr. Aber eine Source-Direct-Taste, die an allen Einstellungen vorbeigeht, damit das Signal noch ein Stück besser wird. Sowas gab es ja damals und das war's. Das heißt eigentlich benutze ich das nur, um meine Quelle auszuwählen, das eine Drehrad und das andere Drehrad, um lauter oder leise zu machen. Und ich will auch gar nicht mehr, das muss einfach funktionieren und tut auch.
Aber Source-Direct war doch nur für den CD-Eingang, ne? Damit man die CDs auch tatsächlich...
Nee, der war für alle Quellen.
Nee, aber es gab so viele Stärken. Die hatten diesen Button, aber den gab's da nur für den CD-Eingang. Weil das musste natürlich für CD, die waren ja... War ja das beste Signal.
Ja, meinen CD-Player hab ich auch noch. Also es ist immer wichtig, wenn man den bewegt, weil der wiegt, keine Ahnung, 12 oder 15 Kilo. Und dann liegt da auf meinem Schreibtisch noch irgendwie das 80 Gramm schwere CD-Laufwerk aus meinem MacBook Pro hier. Und ich kann schwören, da kommt bei beiden genau das Gleiche raus, nämlich die Bits. Und ja, früher mussten wir halt 12 Kilo dafür verwenden.
Nee, den hab ich nicht mehr, der ging irgendwann nicht mehr. Der hat dann nur noch halbe CDs abgespielt.
Nee, doch, ich glaub, meiner tut noch.
Was ja auch, wo wir jetzt gerade bei diesem ganzen Vintage-Audio-Zeug sind, neu rauskam, ist ja, es gibt ja eine neue Auflage von dem Technics SL-1200.
Von dem Plattenspieler? Aber begrenzte Auflage oder so, war da nicht irgendwas? Hab das auch letztens irgendwo gelesen.
Begrenzte Auflage ist glaube ich diese vergoldete Variante. Aber grundsätzlich haben sie ihn überhaupt erst mal wieder aufgelegt.
Ja, Schallplatten sind wieder im Kommen. Wenn du mal bei Dussmann an der Friedrichstrasse gehst, die haben immer noch fetter eine eigene Schallplattenabteilung. Also Liebhaber kaufen halt keine CDs, weil das ist irgendwie tot.
Das ist so eine Mode mit dem Vinyl.
Ja, aber bei meiner CD ist Cover Art hinter dieser komischen Acryl- oder Plastikscheibe und die verkratzt halt und dann sieht das Cover Art dahinter auch nicht mehr so schick aus. So eine Schallplatte, da ist die Kunst sozusagen ohne Plastikfenster davor. Und das ist schon Kunst auch, vielleicht nicht bei allen Platten, aber...
Ja, was ich mich frage, gibt's denn...
Ich muss ja auch nochmal anmerken, Schallplatten, ja? Kommen ja aus der Nische nicht raus.
Aus welcher Nische?
Ja, aus ihrer Nische.
In welcher Nische sind sie denn?
In der Schallplatten-Nische.
Wissen sie denn?
Na CD's kommen auch aus der CD-Nische nicht raus. Warum hat eigentlich noch niemand einen rein optischen Schallplattenspieler gebaut? Also ich meine, dieses mit der Nadel da in der Rille rumkratzen, das kann es ja nicht sein.
Mit Laser-Tasten.
Echt? Gibt's?
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das kaufen kannst, aber das haben die schon gemacht. Doch! Genau. In dem Artikel, wo auch stand, dass sie der Technix rauskamen, da stand auch drin, dass es von Sony auch irgendwie einen gibt, und zwar speziell zum Vinyl-Mastern oder irgendwie, weiß ich schon. Und da war irgendwas. Ich weiß nicht, ob der das mit Laser macht, aber die gehen da halt irgendwie ganz speziell ran und kostet da auch aber nur 500 Euro oder das Ding. Also alles nicht so die Welt, glaube ich. Und die hatten auch schon eingebauten, für Schallplatte brauchte man noch mal so eine Art Vorverstärker, oder hat es da so eine Schallplatten-Eingang an der Anlage? Weil das Signal schwächer war und der hatte schon das gleich auf Line-In-Höhe angehoben.
Das Problem ist ein anderes. Und zwar, die Art, wie die Schallplatte abgetastet hat, führt dazu, dass du die, also wenn du die Spur schreibst, die Bässe mehr Raum brauchen als die Höhen, weil die mehr Ausschlag machen. Ich kann es jetzt nicht genau erklären, warum das so ist, aber damit du nicht zu viel Platz auf der Platte verbrauchst, senkt man beim Schneiden der Platte die Bässe ab und zieht sie dann hinterher. Wenn du die Platte abspielst, musst du dann einen Filter anwenden, der genau den gegenteiligen Effekt hat, sodass du die Bässe hinten wieder hochhebst, damit es wieder klingt.
Verstehe, das ist ja so ein bisschen wie Dolby, wo sie halt die Musik, die im Rauschbereich war, einfach ein bisschen verschoben haben und danach wieder zurückgeschoben haben und das Rauschen war aber weg.
Bei Dolby machst du eigentlich so eine Art Dynamikkompression. Und zwar eine frequenzabhängige Dynamikkompression, die du hinterher beim Abspielen wieder rausnimmst. Damit du die leisen Stellen, also du machst die leisen Stellen quasi lauter aufs Band, damit die einen höheren Abstand zum Rauschen haben. Und wenn du es wieder abspielst, ziehst du diesen höheren Abstand zum Rauschen wieder ab. Weil aber das Magnetband in den Höhen stärker rauscht, als in den Bessen, machst du diesen Effekt auch in den Höhen stärker als in den Bessen. Das ist so ein, wenn man sich die Kurven anguckt, ein bisschen höhere Wissenschaft. Deswegen hat ja auch der Herr Dolby da so viel Geld mit verdient.
Ja, zu Recht aber, oder?
Ja, das hat schon was gebracht.
Ich fand schon, da wären wir dann wieder bei den Walkmans, die Dolby C hatten, aber das Thema hatten wir ja schon mal.
Ja, ich glaube, letztes Mal, oder?
Letztes Mal weiß ich nicht, das ist schon ein Jahr her oder so.
Ja, und dann gab es doch noch eine kurze Zeit dieses DBX.
Das war nicht mehr meins, keine Ahnung.
Und dann ist der Markt auch schon zusammengeklappt.
Ja, danach war CD.
Genau, danach war nicht mehr Audio-Kassette. Danach war MP3, ne?
Ja, da hat es dann auch erst mal wieder gerauscht. Durch die ganzen Wandlungen, die da vorgenommen wurden, mit relativ mageren Equipment.
So, das war jetzt aber ein kurzer Werbeblock.
Wenn es euch so gefällt, das Ding. Wie gesagt, beim nächsten Mal kommt dann hoffentlich der Sennheiser Noise Cancellation Kopfhörer.
Gut, aus der Abteilung. Coole Sachen gibt es auch. Leider funktioniert hier mein Chaptermarking gerade mal wieder überhaupt nicht. Zu Chaptermarking sag ich noch was. Nerv, Reif, zu Hilfe. Das funktioniert nicht. Ich hab was entdeckt. Das muss ich einfach mal erwähnen. Und zwar, wo wir nämlich gerade bei so Vintage-Zeug sind. Ihr erinnert euch ja, es gab ja mal Videotext. Also gibt's natürlich auch immer noch. Ja, gibt's immer noch.
Mag sein.
Es gibt da sogar richtige Redaktionen dafür. Holgi hat sich da mal längere Zeit verdingt.
Ich kannte auch mal jemand, der sich längere Zeit verdingt in der Teletext.
Ja, das ist ja auch immer noch ein lustiges Ding, dass du sozusagen automatischen Begleittext hast zur Video. Dass du sozusagen Untertitel live einblenden kannst. Das ist ja eine tolle Sache. Und als sie dann irgendwie angefangen haben hier zum Grand Prix de la Chanson de Revision, wo ich immer noch abblende, das ist C zu nennen, aber egal, ihr wisst schon welche Veranstaltung ich meine, als sie dann angefangen haben bei der Live-Übertragung da irgendwie lustige Tweets, die sie irgendwie mit einem bestimmten Hashtag geschickt bekommen haben, da automatisch einzublenden, wurde diese Veranstaltung ja nochmal so richtig lustig. Aber davon ganz abgesehen, ist es ja vor allem einer der ersten digitalen Textdienste, die überhaupt sozusagen diesen Planeten betreten haben.
Zumindest eine gewisse Massenadoption hatten.
Es gab ja, also es war ja weit vor SMS und es gab nur Telex. Und das, wenn ich jetzt nicht irgendwas verpasst habe. Und es gab quasi Bildschirmtext seit so 83. Also Bildschirmtext in gewisser Hinsicht. Minitel, also Dezept-Standard, das war so das eine. Und dann gab es halt, ich weiß gar nicht, wann ging das überhaupt los mit Videotext? Und wurde das eingeführt? Klage ich doch mal in der Wikipedia nach. Gott sei Dank ist das relevant genug.
In der Bildaustastlücke. Wie viele Bites passen da rein?
Anfang der 70er Jahre kamen Fernsehtechniker der BBC auf die Idee, diese Bildaustastlücke zu füllen. Und dann haben sie 74 den Teletext-Standard definiert. Guck an, da war ich mir auch nicht so sicher. Was aber damals natürlich nicht getan wurde, das Ganze wurde natürlich nicht archiviert. Also, sie haben das geschrieben, das in ihrem Computer.
Das versendet sich.
Sie haben das gesendet und damit war es dann weg. Und es ist auch so, dass eine normale VHS-Aufzeichnung, prinzipbedingt, dass ich jetzt nicht genau erklären kann, zwar diese Abtastlücke irgendwie auch ein bisschen so mitspeichert, aber nicht so, dass das Signal fehlerfrei erhalten bleibt.
Aber, es bleibt... Ja, ich glaube, das Ding am Videorecorder ist, der schreibt ja schräge Spuren. Und dadurch, dass du hast eine Trommel, da ist ein Kopf drauf und der steht schräg zum Band.
Genau, damit sie das schön breit nutzen können.
Genau. Und du hast immer das Problem, dass der Kopf natürlich irgendwann unten angekommen ist und dann auf der anderen Seite oben wieder schreiben muss. Also du hast, glaube ich, zwei Köpfe oder so. Also immer, wenn der eine unten verschwindet, dann geht der andere oben rein. Aber du hast halt nie so ein 100%iges, dass du wirklich ein kontinuierliches Signal schreibst. Und das synchronisierst du natürlich am besten mit der Bildaustast-Lücke. Sodass das, was in der Bildaustast-Lücke ist, nicht mit aufs Band kommt. Weil du in dem Fall dann gerade diesen Takeover von den Köpfen hast.
Genau, so. Und deswegen ist das sozusagen eigentlich nicht geeignet dafür, das aufzuzeichnen. Aber ein bisschen was bleibt doch hängen. Und jetzt gibt's irgendwie so einen Engländer, der hat sich mal die Mühe gemacht und hat alte VHS-Tapes genommen, wo so irgendwelche Filme aus dem Fernsehen aufgenommen wurden. Und hat das durch so einen selbstgeschriebenen Digitalisator geschickt. Und obwohl so diese Bildseiten nicht federfrei erfasst wurden, wurde eigentlich jede Seite, wo irgendwelche Zeichen waren, dann doch mal tatsächlich dekodierbar und dann auch richtig. Und dadurch, dass er dann aber stundenlang das Material analysiert hat und immer wieder von derselben Seite zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt denselben Inhalt mehrfach hatte, hat er dann einfach nach so einem statistischen hier habe ich jetzt dreimal ein E gehabt und hier habe ich ein A, dann ist es wahrscheinlich ein E, hat er tatsächlich aus diesen alten Zeiten mit alten Tapes den Videotext-Content der 70er und 80er Jahre wieder hervorgeholt. Teletext Time Travel heißt das Projekt. Einfach ein geiler Hack, Jason Robertson heißt der Typ und hat sozusagen, das glaube ich, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das oder auch irgendwas geopensourced hat oder ob er jetzt nur die Seiten online hat. Ich sehe jetzt hier erstmal nur so Directories, wo er so halt alte Tapes von BBC 2, was auch immer, genommen hat und dann kannst du dich da durchklicken. Also Kurt ist jetzt hier nicht da, keine Ahnung. Wäre natürlich mal auch interessant, weil ja die Technik ist ja dieselbe wie in Deutschland.
Kannst du das nochmal kurz anklicken, was du da hast? Ja, einfach mal einen von denen. Da war nämlich gerade eins, da lief irgendwie der Sekunden-Ding ins da durch.
Hier ist irgendwas kaputt. Was hatte ich denn da gerade vorher? Der Sekunden-Dings?
Hatt ich das Gefühl, weiß ich nicht, ob mich das jetzt wieder...
Also, das ist ein Fernsehprogramm. Also hier ist auch noch ein paar Bugs drin, also es ist nicht komplett fehlerfrei.
Ich erinnere mich damals, dass wenn du das live geguckt hast und dieses Teletext aufgemacht hast, dann wurden ja die Seiten, die wurden ja nacheinander in der Loop immer wieder geändert. Und du hast dann gesagt, ich werde Seite 212 aufrufen. Und dann hat er so lange Seiten durchgeguckt, bis er die 212 gefunden hat und hat die dann angezeigt. Und wenn jetzt das Signal aber scheiße war, dann hat er die mit Fehlern angezeigt und hat, wenn sie das nächste Mal kam, dann die wieder überschrieben und dann waren die Fehler an der anderen Stelle und so weiter. Also das war schon damals live so, wenn das Signal nicht so toll war.
Genau, im Prinzip hat er gesagt, das wiedergemacht, merkt sich bloß sozusagen die Häufigkeit der Fehler und wenn halt etwas besonders oft aufkommt, geht er halt davon aus, dass es eben richtig ist. Wäre natürlich auch interessant, mal sowas auf deutschen Tapes zu machen, fand ich jetzt einfach vom Hackvalue einfach eine geile Idee, weil das einfach eine wunderbare Vintage-Technologie-Geschichte ist und auch so einen datenarchäologischen Charakter hat. Da werden wir noch in mehr solcher Probleme kommen. In England ist ja auch irgendwie das mit diesen Computer, mit dieser Computer-History, da ist ja auch so viel zu holen in England. Also die haben ja wirklich was geleistet.
Also ich kann mir bei den öffentlich-rechtlichen deutschen Fernsehsendern sogar vorstellen, dass die da noch Archive von haben.
Digitale gespeichert von dem, was die damals in den 80er Jahren rausgesendet haben?
Möglich wäre das. Also wundern würde es mich nicht. Vielleicht auch auf alten 8-Zoll-Testketten oder so.
Doch mich würde es wundern. Ich würde nicht sagen, ich halte es nicht für möglich, dass ich mich wundere, aber wird dann sagen, okay, dass ihr daran schon gedacht habt, ich kann mir das nicht so richtig vorstellen, ich kriege ja irgendwie auch sonst nichts ordentliches archiviert. Na ist doch so. Denis, du als Display-Experte, sollte sich das doch freuen. Kannst du mal auf deinem, du weißt was, du hast ein BTX-Interface für dein Display im Club, da würde es sich ganz gut machen.
Aber da kann ich auch kurz was erzählen, und zwar gestern hatten wir da auch kurz mal einen Film laufen lassen, weil wir haben ja mal mal Gäste, denen wir zeigen, was dieses Display so kann, und natürlich nehmen wir da mal einen Film und lassen den abspielen. Da meinte einer schon, sag mal, hier wenn so ein Film Untertitel hat, dann könnte man den noch eigentlich direkt unten auf dem Display in der letzten Zeile als richtig perfekt ASCII-Text einblenden, ohne dass es im Film so reingerendert sein muss, und man ja dann doch wieder so Scheiße erkennen kann. Und da meinten wir ja, coole Idee aber haben wir nicht, und dann hat er da losgelegt und den Film auf 19 Zeilen, weil es hat ja 20 auf 19 Zeilen verkürzt, und hat schon angefangen unten in der letzten Zeile so ein bisschen die Subtiles anzuzeigen, aber es hat noch nicht so ganz geklappt, aber die Idee war auf jeden Fall cool, und das wird es dann wohl demnächst geben.
Also die Subtile jetzt aus SRT-Files oder aus entsprechenden Spuren in...
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was er genau gemacht hat, aus welchen Files die da kamen. Manchmal sind die ja in dem Film schon drin, manchmal gibt es ja externe, diesen SRT-Files, welche Quelle er da hat, weiß ich nicht. Aber dass es auf jeden Fall zum Display als Text hingeht und mit dem eigentlichen Bild nichts zu tun hat.
Ja, habt ihr da auch den entsprechenden Zeichensatz?
Ja, wir haben da einen Zeichensatz drin. Nein, CodePage 437 haben wir. Den hat der Marco aus dem Club zusammengeschustert. Das wollen wir auch demnächst ändern nach Unicode natürlich. Aber unser Display kann CodePage 437.
Also der DOS-Zeichensatz?
Genau. Das ist ein bisschen historisch, da hat der Marco zusammengeklickt. Wir haben ja 8x8-Zeichen. Da wir aber nach oben und unten Rand haben, müssen wir uns da keinen Platz lassen zum nächsten Zeichen. Nach links und rechts haben wir aber keinen Rand. Da muss man immer einen Space zum nächsten Buchstaben lassen. Deswegen hatte das eine spezielle Anbeforderung. Nein, weil es nur schwarz-weiß und zu wenig Auflösungen gibt.
Ja, das ist ein Untertitel. Ich finde Untertitel immer noch underused. Es müsste eigentlich mehr geben.
Ich finde Untertitel gerade so, wenn man in der Firma irgendwas guckt, relativ gut, weil man will nicht immer irgendwie den Truppführer rauskramen und so, sondern einfach schnell gucken.
Auch wenn man so prokrastiniert oder was?
Ja, so zwischendrin, irgendjemand empfiehlt einem schnell mal einen Link, dann will man es gucken und dann will man... Eigentlich würden wir die Untertitel haben, weil...
Da steht doch dann immer nur...
Obwohl solche Untertitel werden auch mal spannend.
Ich fände Untertitel geil, als ich mir jetzt neulich dieses Star Wars Binge Watching angetan habe. Was hatte ich eigentlich letztes Mal erzählt? Achso, ich hatte erzählt, dass ich mir diese Specialized Version angeschaut habe und dann bin ich ja auch noch mal mit Episode 1, 2, 3 eingestiegen, weil ich wollte ja herausfinden, ob ich Episode 3 überhaupt jemals gesehen habe. Und weißt du was?
Du hast nicht? Nee. Ja, ich auch nicht.
Angriff der Klonen Krieger oder welcher war das?
Nee, das ist ja der zweite. Der dritte ist The Return of the Sith, ne, heißt der doch.
Kann sein.
Das ist wirklich so, als hätte es diesen Film nie gegeben.
Alle drei nicht.
Wie alle drei nicht?
Alle drei scheiße.
Aber du hast alle drei gesehen.
Glaub schon.
Siehst du, das ist interessant, oder? Man kann sich da gar nicht dran erinnern.
Nee, weil die waren ja auch scheiße. Ich hab den halt alle drei gesehen, wusste schon nach dem ersten, das geht gar nicht und den Rest, keine Ahnung, so ein bisschen.
Also man muss ihn ja zugute halten, dass der zweite etwas besser ist als der erste. Und der dritte ist auch noch mal besser als der zweite.
Ja, weil das Kinderzeug ist halt mehr verschwunden, weil der halt älter wurde. Aber mit den Kindern ist halt langweilig. Kann man es für Kinder machen, aber dann ist es halt so kinderförmig.
Wie das Kinderzeug?
Na ja, dieses erste mit dem Ben Hur-Rennen da und so weiter.
Das fand ich aber cool. Ja.
Das Ben Hur-Rennen.
Hast du mal Ben Hur gesehen?
Ja, das ist Ben Hur. Ja, ja, schon klar.
Also das muss ich dem ersten zugute halten. Also das war dieses Portrait, das war gut. Ob jetzt das Rennen als solches noch hätte irgendwie besser sein können oder so, aber die Idee war gut. Also das war gut.
Also das war gut.
Also das war gut. Krassen Jet-Maschinen, die halt wie so Pferdegespanne geführt werden und dann halt auch diese Kämpfe eben wirklich wie bei Benua. Das fand ich super. Das Schlimme ist einfach Jar Jar Binks. Und ich bin in diesen Film reingegangen, ich wusste ja, ich hab den ja schon mal gesehen und ich dachte mir so, vielleicht ist es gar nicht so schlimm mit dem Jar Jar Binks. Vielleicht war das einfach nur so ein Schock. Und wenn man das... Aber wenn man das Jahre später nochmal anschaut, denkt man sich so, ja okay, ist nicht so schlimm. Es geht ja eigentlich um die Story.
Ich fand den Jar Jar Binks gar nicht so schlimm, aber ich fand ihn so drollig, weil er so ein schönes Jamaikanisch geredet hat.
Ich hab den auf jeden Fall dann gesehen und vom ersten Moment an durchfuhre mich schon wieder so ein Blitz und dieses Fremdschirm ging einfach nicht weg. Es ist auch so traurig. Ich meine, er hat einfach sein komplettes Lebenswerk geschafft, in 15 Minuten zu ruinieren.
Da gibt es ja so einen Typ, der hat so einen Artikel geschrieben, wo er der Meinung wäre, Jar Jar Binks wäre ja eigentlich ein Beherrscher der Force und wäre irgendwie auf der Dark Side und haste nicht gesehen und überhaupt, ja, Jar Jar Binks halt, der eigentliche Bösewicht. Und vielleicht ist das ja der große Bösewicht von der Episode 7. Aber sei es drum.
Ich habe irgendwo noch so ein Interview gesehen mit dem Typen, der irgendwie diesen Jar Jar Binks gesprochen hat.
Und?
Ja, ja und wie er sich denn so fühlt als most hated Role des Star Wars Universums. Na er trug es mit Fassung, sag ich mal.
Ja, was willst du auch machen?
Aber er hat es liebst zu besonderer Popularität gebracht in dieser Rolle. Ja, also das ist wirklich, muss ich sagen, also Jar Jar Binks. Ich hatte ja davon berichtet, dass es wohl auch Versionen gibt ohne Jar Jar Binks. Ich habe mich aber so ein bisschen gewundert, wie die wohl aussieht, weil ich hab die noch nicht...
Ausgeschnitten oder wie?
Der kommt da am Anfang richtig viel vor und der ist richtig viel in der Handlung. Das ist ja das Schlimme. Also wenn der wirklich so easy rauszuschneiden wäre, weißt du, okay. Und in der zweiten Folge ist er ja auch noch da und nervt so ein bisschen, aber ist schon so ein bisschen zur Seite geschoben. Und in der dritten Episode ist er ja nur noch so, läuft da so vorbei, ist so mit in der Truppe, sagt hallo und geht wieder. Aber ich glaube, der spricht gar nicht mehr. Und was mich auch noch extrem gewundert hat bei dem dritten, also jeder kennt Darth Vader. Darth Vader ist einfach der Inbegriff des Bösewichts überhaupt schlechthin geworden. Find ich so.
Er ist auch gut designt als Bösewicht.
Genau, also das ist einfach, das Ding hat eingeschlagen wie eine Bombe.
Mit seinem deutschen Wehrmachtshelm und so.
Ja, er ist einfach mal böse. Er ist einfach the evil und das sah es irgendwie gleich von Anfang an. Dann kam irgendwie diese Episode 1. Episode 1 war ja auch nicht nur dieses Jar Jar Binks, sondern was auch in Episode 1 und 2 gar nicht ging, war dieses permanente Politiker-Geschwafel. Ich meine, das ist ja Star Wars 1 und 2, das hat ja so den Appeal von Bundestag TV.
Kannst du sie erinnern?
Ja, das ist nur der Trailer, der gut war. Aber dieser Film selber, also wirklich, was für ein Gänner. 2 ist dann halt auch so ein bisschen so, da hab ich das ganze Gefühl gehabt, ich gucke irgendwie das fünfte Element. Ich war so mit fliegenden Autos und das nahm ja auch überhaupt gar keine Ende und die ganze Zeit dieser permanente Verkehr.
Stimmt, die Assoziation hatte ich auch.
Und dann dachte ich mir auch so, sag mal, geht's noch, ich will hier in eine Traumwelt entfliehen und ich sehe den ganzen Tag nur Verkehr. Als welches in Japan im Stau. Und dann immer wieder dieses blöde Senator, hier und diese ganze Polit-Scheiße und Korruption und das kann man schon mal irgendwie unterbringen, aber es war einfach too much. Und naja, die Sache mit den Bösewichtern. Jetzt muss ich gerade noch mal überlegen, was war denn noch mal im zweiten Teil der dominante Bösewicht. Im ersten war es dieser Darth Maul, dieser bunt tätowierte mit Doppellichtschwert, der wurde ja dann von Obi-Wan irgendwie zerteilt, nachdem er den Liam Neilsen irgendwie gekillt hat. Also irgendeiner muss ja mal sterben und einer fällt in die Hand. Und dieser Darth Maul war sozusagen in der 1, sondern in der 2, das kriege ich jetzt gar nicht mehr parat, weil wo man da ja auch wirklich die ganze Zeit schwer atmen muss, das ist ja diese diese diese titanikartige Love Story da mit Anakin und der Amidala. Und das steckt man dann irgendwie auch noch weg. So, und in der dritten gibt es ja dann auch nochmal so einen Bösewicht. Max Snyder sagt es gerade im Chat, genau, General Grievous. Und der hat überhaupt nicht verfangen. Ich habe in meinem Leben noch nie diesen Namen gehört, obwohl dieser Film jetzt wie lange schon in den Kinos war? Ewig. Aber dieser Grievous, der hat es einfach überhaupt nicht in die Popkultur geschafft. Null. Ein Roboter-Evil. Also der ist ja so ein Klonen-Roboter. Ja, den gibt es sozusagen noch mal so als Chef. Also dieser Klonen, äh, Entschuldigung, nicht Klonen, sondern wie heißen die Roboter, diese Droid-Armee. Und deren Chef ist halt so ein Ober-Droid. Genau. Der dann halt in der letzten Szene mit irgendwie vier Armen und vier Lichtschwärtern gleichzeitig gegen, äh, gegen, äh, gegen wen eigentlich? Gegen Obi-Wan, glaube ich, kämpft.
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr.
Ich hab halt schnell festgestellt, Mann, du hast diesen Film noch nie gesehen. Also ich hatte immer so dieses, ich wusste immer nicht, ob ich den dritten gesehen habe, aber dann wusste ich so, oh, den hab ich nicht gesehen. Und zwar merkte ich das schon Mitte des zweiten, weil da muss ich schon irgendwie eingeschlafen sein, das letzte Mal. Also ich glaube, ich bin bei dem letzten Mal, beim zweiten muss ich, entweder hab ich abgeschaltet oder bin eingeschlafen, weil der Schluss des Films war mir neu. Den Anfang kannte ich genau, aber der Schluss war mir irgendwie neu. Da weiß ich schon gar nicht, was mit mir passiert ist. Wahrscheinlich war ich so abgetörnt, dass ich irgendwie eingeschlafen bin und dann vielleicht geträumt habe ich den dritten schon gesehen. Nein, das war dann der dritte sozusagen für mich neu, war auch ganz interessant, weil ich halt diese Anknüpfung an Episode 4 sozusagen noch überhaupt gar nicht präsent hatte. Das war mir noch gar nicht klar, wie das eigentlich alles ausgeht. Und dass da ja Chewie irgendwie auf diesem Chewie-Planeten, wo die ganzen anderen Wookies sind, also auf dem Wookie-Planeten meine ich.
Ich glaube, ihr habt ja auch nicht gesehen den dritten.
Ja, da gab es mehr als einen Wookie.
Ich hab den dritten nicht gesehen, da bin ich mir relativ sicher. Aber ich hab die noch nicht die Specialized-Version, also die quasi Original-Original-Version damals mal auf analoge Laserdisc gesehen. Und das ist schon extrem anstrengend, weil ein Film kommt halt auf drei Laserdiscs und die haben zwei Seiten.
Das heißt, du musst irgendwie fünfmal wechseln?
Ja, du musst alle Viertelstunde musst du diese dämliche Laserdisc wechseln. Und das, obwohl die fast LP groß sind.
Jaja, ach echt, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Da gab es ja einen Laserdisc-Grip, den sie halt als MKV oder was auch immer, weil die Laserdisc war in relativ guter Qualität und noch nicht umgeschnitten, weil die DVDs, die rauskamen, das war ja schon so, wo der Solo nicht den Typen erschossen hat, sondern andersrum, wo sie schon gefuscht haben. Und Laserdisc war sozusagen noch die Originalversion in guter Qualität und dann gab es einen Laserdisc-Grip und so. Und ja, kann mich noch erinnern.
Und die waren halt dann, aber die waren halt dadurch, dass sie doppelseitig waren, aber so groß halt auch total unhandlich. Man konnte die dann irgendwie auch nicht richtig anfassen. Und dann mussten die natürlich sauber sein, weil die hatten keine Fehlerkorrektur, die waren ja analog und das die Dinge sich nicht durchgesetzt haben, ist irgendwie so, naja. Aber wie gesagt, ich kannte da damals einen, der hatte halt so ein Laserdisc-Recorder, Abspielgerät, das Teil war auch so, keine Ahnung. Also heute bauen Leute 3D-Drucker in so ein Gehäuse rein. Das war so ein Riesending, irgendwie so eine halbierte Waschmaschine, wo man halt vorne in die Schublade, die Riesenschublade dieses Teil da reingetan hat.
Wird hier gerade nochmal korrigiert bzw. ergänzt. Also in Nummer 2 war der Bösewicht Count Dooku, genau. Das war ja auch der Schauspieler, der immer den Dracula gespielt hat. Und was ich nicht wusste, dieser Grievous war mal ein Mensch und hat so ein Biowesen. Genau, der hatte nämlich so Bio-Innereien und da war er dann irgendwie angreifbar und der Rest war dann sozusagen drumherum gebaut. Okay, soviel habe ich das in dem Moment nicht geschnellt. Wie ich ja überhaupt nur drauf kam, war ja die ganze Sache mit den Untertiteln. Und das hätte mir in dem Moment geholfen, aber leider hatte ich in dem Moment keine. Weil ich finde ja Untertitel sind einfach super zum Lernen anderer Sprachen. Es gibt ja nichts geileres, als wenn du dir sozusagen eine Sprache reinpfeifst in Original-Film-Material, weil es macht Spaß zuzuhören, hast einen Sinn, der Handlung zu folgen, schränkst dich an, schaffst es aber nicht und kriegst dann in dem Moment noch die Untertitel, also sozusagen nicht übersetzt, sondern Originalsprache mit dieselben Texten.
Trainspotting wäre so ein Kandidat. Und es ist dann schon sehr schwierig.
Ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Rankers. Oder aber in Belgien, in Skino.
Schottisch?
Naja, nee, es ist nicht richtig Schottisch. Das ist so Nordenglisch.
Nee, sind doch Schott und sie regen sich doch auf, dass sie von den lame Engländern irgendwie übernommen wurden.
Naja, auf jeden Fall ist es extrem schwer zu verstehen. Nee, in Belgien ins Kino gehen ist auch immer geil. Da kommt dann der Film auf Englisch und dann mit niederländischen und französischen Untertiteln. Das ist halbe Bild voll. Und wenn du dann irgendwas auf Englisch nicht verstehst, ist meistens nicht mehr genug Zeit, es dann auf Französisch oder Niederländisch nachzulesen.
Hab letztens auch einen Film geguckt, der heißt Rundskopp. Oder auf Englisch hieß er, glaube ich, Bullhead. Das war auch ein belgischer Film. Und zwar über eine Geschichte, die über die, wie nennen sie das? Nein, die das in Englisch, die Language-Border rübergeht. Also auf der anderen Seite des Flusses haben die sozusagen Flämisch gesprochen, auf ihrer Seite Französisch. Und der eine noch immer so ein bisschen Deutsch sprechende der auch. Also das war schon alles ein bisschen kompliziert im Film. Und dann aber mit englischen Untertiteln. Und der Film ist gut, aber ist schon so ein bisschen anstrengend. Also wer es mal probieren will, der Film heißt Rundskopp. Und der Schauspieler ist gerade voll im Kommen, der das da macht. Ja, mach ich, mach ich.
Linkoid won't happen in the show notes.
Genau, gib uns einen Podcast-Tipp zum Thema Star Wars. Mal kurz klicken. Radio Tatooine. Ah, der deutsche Star Wars Podcast. Ist ja auch lustig. Episode 37, das Erwachen der Macht 2. Da sind sie aber mit ihren Zahlen komplett durcheinander gekommen.
Mein Lieblings Star Wars ist ja immer noch Star Wars of Kölsch. Was mir jetzt mal hier gefällt ist ja, virales Marketing, das muss man einfach gucken.
War das nicht Schwäbisch?
Ja, Schwäbisch, genau. Kölsch war nochmal was anderes. Ja, Star Wars. Ich muss mir den neuen ja noch angucken. Ich hab den ja noch nicht gesehen.
Ja, also der ist schon fast tragisch, der neue.
Warum?
Aber besser als die anderen, die letzten drei, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, warum. Also spätestens als dieser Herr der Ringe in Moria-Szene kommt, dachte ich so, jetzt geht's aber ab hier. Irgendwie, ich weiß nicht.
Ich bin gerade etwas beeindruckt hier von der Appearance von diesem Radiotatooinen-Podcast, der tatsächlich auf dem Portal auf Publisher läuft, weil sie sich hier so Theming-technisch mal ein bisschen mehr reingeschmissen haben und ganz ordentliche Präsentationen ihres Contents auf die Backe bekommen haben. Da hab ich ja immer noch so ein bisschen Angst davor, mal ordentlich in die Theming-Welt einzugreifen. Leute, wenn ihr das hört, irgendwie, das sind so genau die Sachen, die wir ganz gerne bei uns im Sendegate als Feedback hätten, wie man mal ordentlich den Podcast zieben kann, weil hier ist irgendwie einiges richtig gemacht. Nur unser Subscrib-Button habt ihr aus irgendwelchen Gründen noch nicht. Radiotatouillen, haben wir nicht gehört, kann ich nicht empfehlen, aber kann ich vielleicht mal drauf hinweisen.
Also mit nicht empfehlen heißt das auch nicht, dass du es nicht empfehlen kannst, sondern kann man nichts zu sagen.
Ich kann mich nicht zum Inhalt äußern, ich fand jetzt nur gerade die Webseite korrekt gemacht. So sollte man eigentlich podcastig präsentieren, mit einem gewissen Aufwand der einzelnen Episoden, Präsentationen und mit Fokus auf die aktuelle Folge usw. Und natürlich Podlauf benutzen finde ich natürlich besonders cool. Gut, dann können wir ja diesen Film- und Untertitelbereich mal beenden. Kannst du noch diese Links noch mal ein bisschen eintragen, Denis, die du da gerade alle zu den Filmen usw. gesagt hast?
Ja, den habe ich schon im Internet geschmissen.
Nicht in den Chat, in unsere Liste bitte. Ja, ich sitze ja hier noch ein paar Stunden heute.
Kommen wir zu...
Obwohl, halt, wir sind noch bei Filmen, bei Filmen sind wir noch, da möchte ich noch kurz was anbringen.
Dann zieht sich doch hier wieder alles in die Länge.
Und zwar seit diversen Jahren machen so ein paar Wahnsinnige aus Australien einen Kurzfilm, nach einer Kurzgeschichte von Terry Pratchett. Ich bin da, ich hab irgendwie, als die raus kamen, irgendwann 92, 93 oder so, hab ich die irgendwann mal im Netz gefunden und runtergeladen und ausgedruckt und irgendwo müsste ich das Papier noch haben. Ich hab die aber nicht mehr so genau im Kopf, wie es geht. Auf jeden Fall, es geht um Cohen the Barbarian, der in seinem hohen Alter von 80 oder so nochmal irgendwie das letzte Mal es krachen lassen will und meint, er müsste jetzt einen Brückentroll erlegen. Und dann kommt natürlich alles anders. Und diese wahnsinnigen Australier machen also seit jetzt fast zehn Jahren irgendwie einen Film, der irgendwie ge-crowdfunded und gebacked wurde und irgendwie aber sich in die Länge zieht. Ich hoffe, dass der in den nächsten zwei, drei Jahren endlich mal fertig wird, weil ich will ihn endlich sehen.
Vor allem dieser Geschichte.
Genau, und der Darsteller von dem Coen, der meinte, wie hat er so schön gesagt, the epiquetest small film ever. Also ich hab hier den, warte mal, ich schmeiß mal eben den Link innen.
Das ist schon sozusagen eine Anspielung an Conan, den Babar.
Ja, natürlich. Und wenn du da mal den Link klickst, da sieht man direkt auch schon an den Bildern, dass das einfach großartig ist, dieser Coen, der irgendwie zwar einen langen weißen Bart hat, aber ansonsten kaum noch Haare. Der ist irgendwie... Also da wollte ich nochmal drauf hinweisen, da kann man jetzt irgendwie, naja, Fiebern ist jetzt so ein, dauert halt noch, aber sie sind dabei und sie machen die Post-Production und machen das, die 3D-Sachen und so weiter. Die ganzen Studiodinger sind irgendwie alle im Kasten.
Ach, der ist komplett in 3D oder was? Nein.
Nein, der ist schon mit richtigen Schauspielern und so, aber die Trolls sind natürlich keine richtigen Schauspieler, sondern die werden als 3D-Figuren in der Post-Production mit eingefügt. Und das Pferd ist auch echt und so weiter. Wie gesagt, wollte ich nur kurz sagen, du kannst jetzt mit deinem nächsten Themenwechsel versuchen.
Was meinst du, ist der fertig?
Na ja, wie gesagt, nachdem sie jetzt schon 9 Jahre gebraucht haben.
9 Jahre?
Ja, weil die das meiste halt am Wochenende gemacht haben. Lustigerweise haben sie halt von Terry Pratchett sehr viel Unterstützung gebracht, bis hin zu dem Punkt, wo er meinte, dass zu dem Intro, was nicht zur Kurzgeschichte gehört, naja, also dieser Dialog vom Intro, den hätte ich ja doch irgendwie anders geschrieben. Und dann meinten sie nur so, ja bitte, bitte. Und dann hat er also irgendwie zu dem Intro von dem Film noch mal einen neuen Dialog geschrieben und dann haben sie ihn nochmal neu gefilmt und so. Also das sind echte Wahnsinnige.
Ich glaube, da ist das Ziel aber auch das Machen und nicht das Fertigwerden, oder?
Ich glaube, das Fertigwerden ist auch ein Ziel, aber sie wollen halt jetzt, glaube ich, wirklich dann den letzten, letztes Quäntchen Qualität rausholen. Also sie haben halt auch so mit so Red-Kameras in 5K gedreht und so weiter. Also ich denke mal, ja.
Das finde ich auch interessant, dass sie nicht von Crowdfunding hier reden, sondern von Crowdpower. Und sozusagen, jeder kann mitmachen und irgendwie Post-Production-Skills mit einbringen.
Ja.
Dürfte dann sehr divers werden.
Das ist irgendwie...
Ja, kommen wir zu... Wir müssen über iPhones reden.
Dann reden wir über iPhones.
Also mal ganz abgesehen davon, dass mein Telefon kaputt ist auf eine skurrile Art und Weise. Das ist jetzt sicherlich keine besonders wichtige Information abgesehen davon, dass es mich natürlich extrem stört. Das fing allerdings alles mal an mit iOS 9 und ich hab immer noch iOS 9 in Verdacht, dass das sozusagen hier mein Ding irgendwie kaputt gemacht hat.
Hattest du das überhaupt schon freigegeben?
Nee, wie?
Schwierig.
Ich hab halt hier zeitgleich mein iPhone und mein iPad aktualisiert.
Mit 921?
Nein, mit 9.
9.0.
Als es rauskam, 9.0. Und sofort danach, nachdem die Dinge wieder hochkamen, ging gar nichts. Also es hing irgendwie. Ich musste diese Geräte wieder ausschalten und nochmal starten und irgendwann ging's dann.
Ja, die malware hat nicht richtig funktioniert.
Was ich dann festgestellt habe, was bis heute ein dauerhaftes Problem ist, ist, dass wenn das Ding einmal aus ist und ich schalte es wieder an, braucht es so 5 Minuten bis 10 Minuten, bis es in der Lage ist, eine Verbindung über das Internet aufzunehmen oder dem WLAN zu joinen. Also es joins sozusagen dem WLAN nicht. Ich kann aber auch nicht das LTE benutzen, sondern wenn ich Browser starte und jedes Tool, was irgendwie versucht auf Internet zuzugreifen, bleibt einfach hängen, hängt da, wird nach einer Minute vom OS gekillt und ich bin wieder da, wo ich herkam. Dann tue ich einfach gar nichts, warte 5 oder 10 Minuten und irgendwann geht es dann wieder.
Und du hast aber jetzt auch das aktuelle 9.2 oder was ist das? 9.2.1 drauf und es ist immer noch so?
Jedes Update hatte ich gehofft, jetzt müssten sie es doch mal gefunden haben, weil es ist...
Ach so, das könnte der Baseband-Chip sein, ne?
Es könnte irgendwas sein, aber es war halt nicht nur auf meinem Telefon im Sinne von, mein konkretes Telefon hat ein Problem, sondern es war exakt im selben Moment innerhalb von einer halben Stunde Update-Aktivität auf zwei vollkommen unterschiedlichen Geräten, im iPhone 5S und im iPad Mini.
Was ist das?
3, 2, 3?
Das erste Retina, das zweite Retina. Das erste Retina ist das 2. Ich hab's neulich extra mal nachgeguckt, weil ich auch durcheinander war.
Und beide haben halt irgendwie dieses Problem. Ganz davon abgesehen, dass mein Akku jetzt auch völlig im Arsch ist und das Gerät halt sich so bei, naja, mal so bei der Hälfte der Ladung irgendwie ausschaltet und so.
Richtig geil.
Immer wenn ich so ein bisschen mehr Strom ziehen will, so ich schalt die Kamera ein, mach ein Foto und dann so.
Lass mich raten, du hast irgendeinen Prozess, der auf 100% läuft. Das macht dein Telefon langsamer und saugt dein Akku leer.
Ja, aber wo soll der herkommen?
Wird der warm? Das Telefon meine ich?
Es geht einfach zuverlässig zu früh aus. Der Akku ist halt einfach...
Durch.
Der ist wahrscheinlich durch. Da dachte ich mir so, naja. Gehst du einfach mal zum Genius Bar, kommst da mit deinem iOS 9 Problem, lässt dir mal ein bisschen was erzählen, so wie du das gewohnt bist.
Die haben ja immer gleich so radikale Maßnahmen, wie alle Einstellungen zurücksetzen und so. Weil denen fällt ja auch nichts ein am Ende, oder?
Weiß ich nicht. Nein sagen hätte ich ja immer noch können. Das Problem war nur, dass ich feststellte, dass sich das irgendwie alles geändert hat. Ich weiß nicht, wann du dir das letzte Mal so einen Genius Bar Termin klicken wolltest. Aber das ist ja noch gar nicht so lange her. Da klickte man irgendwie auf apple.de Retail, suchst du sich einen Store aus, sagt hier Genius Bar Termin, ja zalala, wann hast du Zeit, hier sind die nächsten Termine. Und ja, Pustekuchen.
Ich hab das das letzte Mal über die App gemacht.
Es gibt diese Seite nicht mehr. Und auch die App funktioniert mittlerweile anders. Du wirst nämlich dann erstmal gefragt, was ist überhaupt dein Problem? So ja, hier irgendwie iPhone, lalala, Batterieprobleme. Und dann so, ja, dann schicken wir dir jetzt erstmal einen Link und den öffnest du bitte mal auf deinem Device und dann erzeugen wir da mal ein Systemreport. Da dachte ich mir so, aha, interessant. Also sie verlagern jetzt sozusagen schon einen Teil der Analyse, den sie sonst vielleicht erst vor Ort gemacht haben, verlagern sie dann schon.
Um die App, die 100% Dings verbraucht, so wie Facebook das ja hatte, schon vorher zu finden und dir zu sagen, das ist das Problem.
Das ist aber nicht das Problem.
Bei vielen war das wahrscheinlich das Problem.
Ja, aber das ist nicht bei mir das Problem. Das Problem ist, wenn ich mit 100% morgens aus dem Dings rausgehe, ist mein Telefon nach zwei Stunden nicht mehr zu gebrauchen. Der Akku hält halt zwei, drei Stunden und also wenn ich das Ding nur so ein bisschen benutze, dann, also ich komm noch nicht mal bei einem halben Tag. Und der schaltet sich dann halt irgendwo zwischen 50% und 20% ab. So nach dem Motto, du hast noch 50% ausgeschaltet, eingeschaltet, du hast noch 17%. Also einschalten, das geht natürlich nur mit Kabel. Machs Kabel ran und dann 20% Differenz zu der letzten Akkuanzeige von vor ein paar Sekunden. Also da ist was braun.
Das ist normalerweise ein Zeichen dafür.
Okay, und was ist dann passiert mit deinem Termin-Tool?
Dann krieg ich halt diesen Link und hab dann irgendwie was geschickt und dann passiert irgendwie gar nichts. Und sie erzählt mir nur so, ach so, ja, übrigens einen Termin haben wir nicht. Also nicht im Apples-Tool. Nein, nein, so haben wir nicht. Für den Buchungszeitraum, den wir so zulassen, haben wir nicht. Aber hier kannst du ja noch zu den anderen Apple-Partnern gehen und hier in Gravistore und Pipapo. Will ich natürlich nicht. Weil mich interessiert natürlich die spezifische Apple-Experience. Ich will ja immer wissen, was die machen. Einfach so unabhängig von der Problemlösung. Aber es ist jetzt gerade einfach gar nicht möglich, zumindest in Berlin nicht da einen Termin zu kriegen. Das ist einfach nicht machbar.
Das hatte ich das letzte Mal mit dem MacBook aber auch. Also dass ich irgendwie ein paar Tage hintereinander immer wieder in die App geguckt hatte, bis sie dann Termine hatten, sofort drauf geklickt hatte. Und dann habe ich Gott sei Dank einen gekriegt. Und dann hatten sie das Ding selber aber irgendwie, das Motherboard in weniger als 24 Stunden getauscht, als ich ex-endlich den Termin hatte.
Es geht nur um diese Slots am Genius Bar, dass du überhaupt einfach eine Empfangsperson hast, die sich halt bis zu einer halben Stunde um dich kümmern kann.
Ja nun, ein Apple Store ist halt zu wenig für Berlin.
Ja, offensichtlich. Ich frage mich halt, wo ist der zweite? Also hier in der Straße ist noch Platz. So ein Obst und Gemüse hat irgendwie eine Platte gemacht.
Da kann jetzt ein anderer Obst und Gemüse rein.
Du meinst Anna Oranienburger?
Keine Ahnung, also ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen, dass es jetzt für Apple in Berlin nicht noch einen zweiten Ort gäbe, wo sie auch noch einen Laden aufmachen können. Und es gab ja auch mal das Gerücht, dass sie in dieser komischen Mall da am Leipziger Platz aufschlagen.
Die alle so hochhypen und irgendwie...
Ach, das ist ja so ein ganz normaler Prolo-Mall.
Ja, im Prinzip.
Genau, das ist der selbe Scheißdreck wie überall auch.
Leipziger Platz? Wo ist der denn?
Das ist dieser Platz, wo lange Zeit diese und immer noch teilweise diese Kulissen-Gebäude stehen.
Dieses Potemkinche-Gebäude steht.
Ach so, dieses Fake-Teil, wo auch immer diese riesen Apple-Werbung hängt und auch Samsung und so. Aber da ist doch nichts. Oder ist das jetzt offen oder...
Nein, nicht in diesem Potemkinche-Gebäude drin.
Es ist ja nur noch ein Haus, so Potemkin, und der Rest ist ja gebaut. Und wo früher das Wertheim-Gebäude war und wo der Tresor war, sozusagen.
Ja, das weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Weißt du nicht, wo der Tresor war? Weißt du nicht, wo der Tresor war? In Berlin? Hallo? Warst du in den 90er Jahren... Warst du da am Leben denn?
Ich bin Nerd.
Da waren alle Nerds im Tresor.
Da gab es ein Chat. Nee, ich war da auch nie drin.
Im Tresor gab es ein Chat-Terminal. Ich bitte euch. Anfang der 90er. Da gab es noch nicht mal weltweit Web.
Ich war mal in diesem anderen Laden. Wie ist der?
E-Werk.
Ja, da war ich mal.
Ja, das war ja schräg gegenüber. Wie auch immer.
Wie auch immer.
Wo war ich? Ah, mein Telefon. Genau. Also sollte irgendjemand von euch Zuhörer im App Store arbeiten, erzählt mir doch mal, wie man einen Termin kriegt. Ich hätte gerne einen. Ich würde gerne mal gut beraten werden. Und ich würde ja fast sagen, vielleicht kauf ich euch mal ein Telefon ab. Aber leider gibt es ja gerade nichts ordentliches.
Aber du würdest immerhin ein Akku kaufen.
Ich würde ein Akku kaufen zum Apotheken Apple-Preis.
Du hast doch noch Garantie auf den 5S oder nicht?
Nee, mir ist ja meins geklaut worden. Und das ist so ein gebrauchtes Teil. Und da ist alles durch. Deswegen stehe ich da ein bisschen auf dem Schlauch. Aber ich habe gehört, dass man dann für 80 Euro Apotheken-Preis kriegt einen neuen Akku. Oder du machst halt hier, glickst du günstig, kannst du dir für 40 Euro dein Bastel-Set machen und selber dein Telefon aufschrauben.
Weil du willst ja die Apple-Experience genießen.
Genau. Ich bin ja jetzt nicht bei dem Club gelandet, damit ich alles selber mache, sondern ich will es ja ordentlich auf die Politik fahren.
Du kannst ja auch hier zum iPhone-Doktor gehen und der baut dir das doch auch ein für 40 Euro, oder nicht?
Das ist aber wieder keine Apple-Experience. Also mein Tipp ist ja immer, alle Einzelteile einsammeln. Man hat manchmal Glück.
Also ich höre auf damit in dem Moment, wo ich da mal scheiße behandelt werde. Dann ist es vorbei. Aber es hat ehrlich gesagt bisher noch nicht stattgefunden.
Nee, wenn man erstmal einen Termin hat, ist immer alles super.
Also vor allem, weil für mich gehört halt dieser Store irgendwie zum Produkt dazu. Das ist für mich kein getrenntes Ding. Der Store ist irgendwie Teil des Gesamtdings. Also finde ich so. Dieses Service-Komponent, ich finde da gar kein gutes Wort für.
Ja, das Einzige, was ich an dem Store komisch finde, ist diese Bezahl-Experience. Wenn du das nicht selber machst, dann gibt es irgendwie keine Schlange, wo du dich anstellen kannst und dann irgendwie, bis du dann jemand gefunden hast, dann weißt du nicht und so. Das ist alles ein bisschen merkwürdig. Aber vielleicht bin ich das erste Deutsch. Ich will mich halt anstellen können.
Echt? Weil ich mich ja nicht auch nicht anstellen kann.
Naja, aber ich meine, da ist halt dieser Typ mit dem Kartenzahldingens da unterwegs und dann stehen da irgendwie sechs Leute rum und dann weißt du nicht, wann bist du jetzt dran, weil die...
Echt, du hast da Probleme gehabt, geldlos zu werden?
Weil die halt so überlaufen sind und du weißt jetzt nicht, wer jetzt der nächste dran ist und... Also das ist nicht so mein Ding.
Naja, wenn sie mal irgendwie Apple Pay eingeführt bekommen, dann geht das ja auch. Auf irgendwas wollte ich doch jetzt hinaus. Ja, genau. Also vielleicht gibt es ja demnächst ein Telefon, was ich mir kaufen möchte. Habt ihr von diesen Gerüchten gehört, dass sie tatsächlich ein 4 Zoll iPhone bringen wollen?
Also die letzten Gerüchte, die ich gehört hab, war, dass sie den Fünfer-Formfaktor nochmal auch wieder in so einer komischen Plastikhäuse C-Variante mit quasi iPhone 6 inner reinbringen, aber das... Gerüchten kann man ja viel, ich meine. Sorry, ich hab immer noch Lounge in der Lunge.
Ja, warum benutzt du hier nicht das vorgeschriebene...
Ja.
Ich hab extra drei neue V-Modes gekauft und hier nachgerüstet, dass wieder alles bestückt ist und dann hustet ihr einfach hier rein. Ich investiere hier nachhaltig und dann sowas.
Dann sowas.
Ja, das ist ja eine Missachtung. Ja, dass es so weitergeht, gibt es ja auch keinen Hall. Also nicht, dass es bisher Hall geben würde, aber ich dachte mir, ich baue das vielleicht nochmal ein. Genau. Eigentlich muss ich das irgendwie nochmal einbauen, mit dem Hall. Naja, auf jeden Fall, dieses 5SE scheint wohl tatsächlich so eine Mini-Version von dem 6er zu werden. Also auch so mit Rund und so.
5SE?
Ja, 5SE. Meinte, meinte die doch üblicherweise extrem gut informierte Quelle Mark Gurman. Das ist ja sozusagen der Einzige, dem man vertrauen kann.
Linken Sie hier. Linken Sie jetzt. Also ich weiß nicht, also naja.
Was? Aber hier ist gar nicht dieses Foto drin. Irgendwo ist so ein Leak.
Nein, aber also so diese Einschätzung, welche Leak-Quellen jetzt besser sind und welche weniger gut sind, naja.
Ja, da hast du wahrscheinlich einfach den Track-Record von Mark Gurman nicht mitbekommen in den letzten Jahren.
Das mag durchaus sein.
Also das ist so derjenige, der wirklich alles akkurat angesagt hat in den letzten Jahren. Also das ist wirklich der mit Abstand best informierteste Gerüchtekoch, keiner weiß, wie er das macht.
Gerüchtekuck.
Genau, der Gerüchtekuck. Und das ist einfach mal so, das muss mal so.
Special Edition. Speed Extended. Enhanced. Was könnte das E noch so stehen? Elongated.
Also hier gibt es, warte mal, hier habe ich irgendwie, das ist glaube ich nicht der Originalartikel, aber hier ist auf jeden Fall dieses Foto zu finden. Hier, dann sieht man so ein iPhone 5 und ein 5S und ein angebliches 5SE daneben. Das ist halt schon, das ist so, an den links ist ein 5er und rechts soll das 5SE sein. Und das hat halt irgendwie so diese Button-Anordnung vom 6er, ein Ausschaltknopf so rechts. Und ist ein ganzer Spaß, aber halt in dem Formfaktor vom 5er und eben aber auch so mit runden Ecken. Also es sieht wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen cheesy aus, aber es ist zumindest nicht so scheiße groß, was ich eigentlich ganz geil finde. Könnte unter Umständen vielleicht was für mich sein, weiß ich nicht. Bin mir noch nicht so sicher.
Ich hab ja heute in der S-Bahn einen gesehen, der hatte ein iPad Pro, das er da so aus der Tasche zog. Und ich dachte so, was? Ich hab dann daneben hier mein schönes 13 Zoll MacBook Pro aufgeklappt und dachte, so ein bisschen kleiner ist auch nicht schlecht.
So, berichte doch mal von deinen iOS 9.3 Beta Eindrücken.
Ja, eigentlich gibt es nichts zu erzählen. Ich hab das hier auf dieses iPad gemacht. Und außer, dass man in den Settings jetzt gucken kann und im About-Dialog steht 9.3 drin, hat man an nicht einem Punkt das Gefühl, es wäre jetzt was anderes. Also ich hatte ja schon auf dieses komische, wie heißt das, Night Shift gehofft, dass das irgendwie jetzt hier so schön gelblich wird, so sonnenuntergangsmäßig, aber nichts dergleichen ist irgendwie da aufgetaucht. Vielleicht will sich Apple noch nicht so ganz in die Karten gucken lassen, wie es funktioniert und hat erstmal nur für Developer halt jetzt so ein paar geänderte APIs eingetütet. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das soll.
Du weißt, all diese Features, von denen sie beschrieben haben, waren nicht da?
Ich hab keine gesehen. Also hier ist nicht mal diese komische News-App drauf. Also ich weiß nicht, was da los ist.
Du hast die Beta 2, ja?
Ja, genau. Also vielleicht muss ich auch einfach nochmal ein Restore-Dingens machen, weil was neu war, das gab es jetzt auch das erste Mal, ist, dass man so ein komisches Profil runterlädt und dann bekommt man einfach ein Update. Also vorher musste man ja irgendwie entweder über iTunes updaten oder ein komplettes Restore machen oder so. Und jetzt kann man nur dieses Profil runterladen und dann sagt der Auto-Updater hier, gibt ein Software-Update und dann hast du 9.1 Beta irgendwas drauf. Also wie gesagt, es gibt nichts zu erzählen. Das ist irgendwie nichts passiert.
Ja, ich denke eh, dass das wahrscheinlich ein relativ enttäuschendes Release werden wird, weil das alles wieder so Features sind, die nur für manche sinnvoll sind und Einzelne werden es toll finden, weil in ihrem Bereich dann gerade mal was passiert ist, was sich so helft, kram und Carplay ablädt.
Ja gut, aber ich meine von Punkt 2 auf Punkt 3, da muss man jetzt irgendwie auch nicht weinen, wenn es jetzt nicht so viele Features hat, oder?
Ja gut, aber sie haben ja ein Feature angekündigt, wo ich so am Anfang ein wenig die Brau lüpfte. Die senkte sich dann allerdings relativ schnell.
Ah ja, das Brauen lüpfen und senken.
Da steckt alles drin, was Emotionalität so hergibt.
Wenn man so viel hat schon.
Na du wirst das ja gelesen haben, dass sie sozusagen jetzt so ein Education-Feature reinbauen?
Na ich hab nur auf der Seite halt iOS in Education, the best classroom experience. Na ja, da kann man halt irgendwie... Also es klingt so wie, es ist so ein Extended Kids irgendwas. Also es sieht nicht nach einem Family Multi-User-Feature aus, sondern wirklich nach...
Genau, da sind wir nämlich beim Punkt. Weil was ja eigentlich in diesem blöden iPad fehlt, für meinen Geschmack, ist halt so ein Multi-User-Ding. Weil ich bin halt immer nicht bereit, iPads, die so voll mit Apple ID konfiguriert sind, irgendwelche in Kinderhände zu geben, die dann erstmal anfangen, was weiß ich, in den Settings erstmal die E-Mail-Accounts zu löschen, die sich dann auch gleich auf alle anderen Rechner zurücksinken und dann ist irgendwie alles im Eimer. Das Potenzial an Datenverlust ist so groß, dazu natürlich auch alle anderen Dienste, die im Prinzip alle fehlbedient werden können, von Dropbox und so weiter. Also gerade durch diese ganze Cloud-Sinkerei hat das ja alles so ausfugt. Man kann sich sagen, warum zahlierst du das da auch alles drauf? Man kann es ja total boy-down abspecken.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Erstens ist das nicht so einfach. Und zweitens, was ist, wenn ich das mal benutzen will? Wo soll man denn das Gerät? Dann will man das doch mal machen. Und dass das so schwierig ist, das einfach mal in so einen Modus zu bringen, mit jetzt benutzt das mal jemand anders. Man mag es nicht glauben, dass zwei Menschen vielleicht auch zwei unterschiedliche E-Mail-Adressen haben. Übrigens könnte es ja sehr einfach sein, wenn man sich diese Apple-ID nicht nur bei installieren angibt, sondern halt einfach mal beim Login. So wie das auf dem Mac seit zehn Jahren ist.
Naja, nicht ganz zehn.
Was?
Zwanzig?
Naja, das Einloggen mit der Apple-ID, das gibt es noch nicht so lange.
Ja, du hast einen Login und du unterscheidest verschiedene User und jeder hat sein eigenes Home-Direktorien, sein eigenes Setup und sein eigenes Permissions und Mail und alles ist getrennt.
Ja gut, das funktioniert seit 91, seit Lackstep 09.
Eben, aber es funktioniert im Jahre 2016 auf iPads, die mittlerweile mehr Performance haben als die Maxx, die sie vor zehn Jahren gebaut hat. Ja, die jetzt so schnell sind wie die aktuellen Laptops, die du kaufen kannst, die kleinsten, die können das nicht. Und ich verstehe ja, dass es da gewisse Bedenken geben kann, was so die Komplexität des Gesamtsystems angeht. Aber jetzt mal ehrlich, was hält sie davon ab? Mit so Sachen wie Touch-ID? Einfach so ein, ja, du kannst hier auch ein zweites Home machen und eine andere Apple-ID eingeben oder ein anderes Login, wie auch immer. Und dann gibt es hier einen Secondary User.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, darüber haben wir doch schon geredet, die wollen Geräte verkaufen, jeder soll sein eigenes iPad haben.
Ja, aber sie zeigen doch jetzt selber mit diesem Education-Produkt, dass dieser Bedarf da ist, wenn auch nur bereit sind, sie in Large-Scale sozusagen, weil genau das machen sie ja jetzt. Du kannst halt hier mit diesem Education, mit diesem School-Manager deine ganzen iPad-Flotte so präparieren, dass die eben auch, also ich hab jetzt nur so in Details gelesen, aber mein Verständnis ist, erstens, die können sich halt so anmelden, du hast halt so quasi so eine Login-Page und kannst sagen, ich bin diese Person und dann ist halt dein Gerät entsprechend eingestellt plus so ein paar weitere Möglichkeiten, mit denen du dann halt auch noch so Aufgaben verteilen kannst, Apps bereitstellen kannst, etc. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie weit das geht.
Ja, also die Login-Page haben sie jetzt nicht gezeigt von dem iPad. Die gibt es nicht zu sehen, aber irgendwie kannst du wohl tatsächlich... Das soll die Login sein. Third Grade.
Also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das jetzt auch nicht der Login, vielleicht ist das so das Management.
Nein, das ist auf jeden Fall die Lehreransicht. Weil du da ja auch siehst, welcher Schüler hat welche App offen und so weiter. Jaja, das ist ja alles sehr auf den Lehrer fokussiert, der dann den Schülern irgendwie verbietet, in irgendeine App reinzugehen. Oder nur die App lockt, oder nur die Seite in dem und dem iBook, dann dürfen sie alle angucken und so weiter. Aber hey, ja.
Find ich auch vollkommen in Ordnung. Also für so ein Classroom Flow ist das halt völlig in Ordnung. Zumal du ja auch noch die Möglichkeit hast, das glaube ich so zu machen, wenn du so eine Flotte hast von, was weiß ich, hast du da so ein mobiles Regal und da stecken dann irgendwie 20 iPads drin und du hast 20 Schüler. Dann kannst du die quasi vorher schon so provisionieren und sagen, ja, hier, 20 iPads, 20 Schüler, lalala und dann zeigt jedes iPad sozusagen schon mal so deinen Namen, deinen Avatar an und du nimmst hier quasi das iPad drauf, wo dein Name drauf steht. Also ist gar nicht so, dass du dich dann einloggen und wechseln und so, aber kannst du es halt eben auch so machen, dass sozusagen jeder schon so sein hat. Und das ist ein ganz cooler Ansatz, aber ich hätte das halt einfach gerne für jedes normale iPad, dass ich da einfach für Familienmitglieder oder wen auch immer einfach auch mal so einen Test-Account machen kann und keine Angst haben muss, dass irgendwie mein Datenbestand dabei komplett tops geht.
Jetzt warten wir erstmal ab, bis diese ganze Kram hier quasi das Licht der Welt erblickt. Eventuell kannst du das sowieso nur machen, wenn du tatsächlich eine Schule bist. Weil nämlich ganz unten hier steht, mit Sicherheit, If you are interested in learning more about these education features, send us an email at educationpreview.apple.com Also es kann sein, dass du dich bei Apple als Schule registrieren musst.
Oh ja, mit Sicherheit, weil du ja dann die Apple-IDs vergibst, die da sind. Du hast sozusagen deinen lokalen Login-Manager und so. Dem ist so und das wird kein Feature sein, was jetzt auf unsere normalen iPads kommt. Und das ist ja das Traurige. Also dass es noch nicht mal so ein Subset davon gibt.
Ich glaube, wenn die ersten Schulen in Kalifornien das benutzen und die ersten Schüler dann kommen und dann kommt Tim Cook in die Klasse und dann sagen 20 Schüler, wollen es jetzt für ihr eigenes iPad zu Hause aber auch haben und die Eltern sagen, sie hätten es für ihre Kinder und ihr iPad auch gerne, dann haben sie vielleicht ein Einsehen.
Na sicher, das wird dir noch nie einer gesagt haben, dass man das braucht. Bestimmt.
Ja, aber wenn es halt mehr Leute und massiver Leute sagen, dann naja, was weiß ich.
Vielleicht.
Kann alles gut werden, Lasse?
Na ja, zumindest haben sie die Technologie dann schon mal da drin und ich weiß es nicht. Ja, du hast ja recht, aber irgendwie...
Du hast recht.
Wir werden es sehen.
Wir werden es sehen, aber wir werden es wahrscheinlich nicht sehen. Das ist nämlich das Ding.
Na ja, es gibt ja immer noch ein iOS 10. Also ich denke mal, dass es in dem 9er-Track nicht mehr mit reinkommt.
Du meinst, dass sie das jetzt mit dieser Education-Geschichte erstmal ausprobieren und danach ausrollen? Kann sein.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie, wenn sie die ersten Erfahrungen damit gemacht haben mit den Education-Dings, dass sie dann sich vielleicht dann auch trauen, hinzugehen und zu sagen, okay, die ersten Apps sind angepasst für den Multi-User-Fall. Jetzt können wir es vielleicht auch mal dann ins ganz normale OS reinmachen.
So ein Gast-Feature wäre auf jeden Fall schon mal cool, wenn Leute sein können, mal dein Telefon kurz zum Surfen benutzen.
Ja, mindestens.
So wie jetzt mit der Kamera auch, kannst dir auch Fotos machen, ohne dass du siehst, was eigentlich in den Fotos drin ist. Und so könnte man es mit Safari auch machen. Kein History, kein nichts, aber du kannst halt surfen.
Surfen, surfen durch die Welt mit Multimedia.
Jetzt nicht anspielen, bitte.
Ist nicht dein Ernst.
Das sind diese Eurocats oder wie sie gießen? Nein, ich sagte jetzt nicht anspielen. Und ich meinte das Ernst.
Können sie jetzt Bonus Track machen? Bonus Track ist gut.
Bono dem sein Track. Ja, der ist halt auch noch ungelegt. Naja, also ich hab da diese neue Wohnung und war dann irgendwie mit dem Hausmeister oder mit diesem Typen, der da die Wohnungsübergabe macht, auch im Keller, weil er mir einen Keller zuweisen wollte, dann stellte sich heraus, dass nicht ganz klar war, welcher Keller dazugehört. Und außerdem sind sowieso vor allem leeren Kellern Schlösser, weil sonst wären sie nicht leer, wie das so ist in Berlinern Kellern. So und da hing dann so eine große Kiste an der Wand, wo so ein Aufkleber drauf war. Prima, komm! Wow und ich dann so, ah, erst mal ein Foto machen. Da stand auch was von Breitbandanschluss und so. Und dann habe ich irgendwie da angerufen. Da habe ich dann angerufen, ja, wie ist denn das hier? Blah, da war so eine Kiste im Keller und ob sie mir denn da irgendwie Internet machen könnten? Ja, was wären die Adresse? Ja, die und die. Ja, nee, da gibt es nur Kabel Fernsehen. Ich so, Fernsehen? Was will ich denn damit? Und der Typ am anderen Ende, dieser Callcenter-Zwerg, der hat dann irgendwie schon so deutlich vernehmend irgendwie geatmet, weil ich das irgendwie wohl nicht goutiert habe, dass er mir jetzt Fernsehen geben wollte.
Das heißt, man hört da immer wieder mehr von, also.
Ja, was will ich damit?
Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung,, auf jeden Fall. Hab ich dann doch irgendwie, hab ich dann bei der Telekom geklickt und das hab ich, wenn man das nicht täglich macht, was ich also auch nicht täglich tue, dann man klickt es auf der Webseite, gibt da auch seine E-Mail-Adresse an und so weiter und ja, wir schicken ihm dann die Auftragsbestätigung. Was hast du geklickt? Na DSL halt.
Ja, was, ordentliches DSL oder nur Kinder-DSL?
Das hängt davon ab, was sie jetzt hinkriegen. Also du kannst halt 50 klicken, mehr gibt's ja nicht.
Ja gut, aber das gibt's zumindest schon mal.
Das konnte man da klicken.
Für deine Adresse konnte man das klicken?
Ja, das konnte man da klicken.
Also du hattest das Versprechen, VDSL zu bekommen?
Ja, Moment, das Versprechen lautet nämlich ganz genau, lautet das Versprechen hier. Also VDSL 50 IP heißt das. Und da steht Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit, 27.900 Kilobit pro Sekunde bis 51.300 Kilobit pro Sekunde im Download. Und 2.700 Kilobit pro Sekunde bis 10.000 Kilobit pro Sekunde im Upload. Auf gut Deutsch, die sagen, wenn nichts durchgeht, geht nichts durch, interessiert uns nicht. Wir nennen es trotzdem VDSL 50.
Weil es ja immer noch schneller ist als das andere.
Ach so, ja, und man denkt so, schicken die Auftragsbestellungen, machen sie natürlich ein paar Posts. Irgendwie so, kriege ich vielleicht eine E-Mail, könnt ihr mir vielleicht sagen, wann es losgeht und so? Also diese ganze Post, das habe ich alles nicht verstanden. Und dann noch etwas, was ich auch noch viel absurder fand, es gibt also dann hier diesen Zettel, da stehen dann vier Nummern drauf. Es gibt also eine Zugangsnummer, irgendwie grob geschätzt zwölfstellig.
Oh ja, das ist geil.
Formalistische Online-Nummer. Dann gibt es ein persönliches Kennwort, ungefähr neunstellig. Dann gibt es eine Anschlusskennung, die ist ungefähr zwölfstellig. Und noch eine Mitbenutzernummer, die ist vierstellig. Und dann denkst du so, what the fuck, kann ich hier einfach das Kabel reinstecken, und es kommt Bits raus? Warum müsst ihr mir diese... Vor allen Dingen auch so alle in einer Zeit, auch ohne Zwischenräume. Also wenn Zwischenräume wären, wären das so wie... So I-Bahn-Nummern, immer so in Viererblöcken, oder meinetwegen auch IPv6-Adressen, mit Doppelpunkten dazwischen oder so. Nein, das ist einfach nur eine Zahlenwüste, so ein Wurm von Zahlen, den du gar nicht eingeben kannst.
Kann ich mal noch mitbindestrichen? Wenn sie zum Beispiel deine Mitbindungsnummer mit der Anschlussnummer kombinieren.
So, und das Beste ist jetzt...
Wissen musst, dass sie das dann in dem Moment getan haben, und es sich nicht wieder um eine komplett neue Nummer handelt. Man weiß nie, was man irgendwo eingeben muss.
Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment. Jetzt steht da, die Daten gelten übrigens auch für das Kundencenter, E-Mail-Center und weitere Services. Unter www.telekom.de-kundencenter-kompass erfahren sie, wie sie ins Kundencenter kommen und welche Funktionen es bietet. So, jetzt musst du da eigentlich mal draufdrücken. Klick, surf das mal an, das nimm ich total geil.
Ja, ich bin ja gerade und zwar...
Ne, ne, auf dem, mit Sound bitte.
Mit Sound?
Ja.
Wie mit Sound?
Also www.telekom.de-kundencenter-kompass Achso, du meinst nicht hier den Login des Kundencenters? telekom.de/kundencenterminuskompass. Ja, natürlich. So und was kriegt man da? Ein Video.
Soll ich das abspielen?
Ja, wo diese etwas bayerisch sprechende Dame erklären, wie es geht?
Das Video hat Telekom über einen Telekom DS1150 mega mit Anschluss an, das ruckelt! Leute!
Genau richtig. Herzlich willkommen in Ihrem Telekom Kundencenter. Kostenlos, rund um die Uhr erreichbar und selbstverständlich auch als App verfügbar. Hallo, ich bin Daniela Montalto und stelle Ihnen heute die unzähligen Möglichkeiten Ihres Kundencenters vor. Es ist voller Funktionen Ihnen das Leben leichter und wertvolle Zeit sparen. Sie haben immer die Möglichkeit, Ihre Rechnungen einzusehen bzw. herunterzuladen. Über Rechnungen, die bis zu anderthalb Jahre alt sind.
Aber das Rollen der R ist doch super, oder?
Sie können natürlich auch ihre persönliche Daten ändern.
Wie bestimmt an deinem Rechner.
Oder Kontaktangaben.
Druckelt.
Ihre sensiblen Daten sind selbstverständlich bei uns sicher.
Klar!
Vielleicht haben Sie eine Tarifoption entdeckt.
Genauso sicher wie das Video drücken Sie auch noch Stückweise raus.
Das ist geil. Wenn man gerade korrigiert, ist das halt fränkisch.
Ja, Franken, meinetwegen. Allmächt ist halt Franken.
Das ist wirklich schlimm, oder? Es ruckelt. Ich mach hier sonst nichts auf dem Netz gerade.
Ich würde das auch gerne ab... Ah, ich kann draufklicken und es gibt keine Play-Control. Das ist wirklich schlimm. Und dann immer diese Windows-Logos, die sie immer noch haben. Das finde ich auch so furchtbar. Diese ganze Icon-Ästhetik ist ja auch noch wirklich so vollkommen......gästrig.
Und jetzt kommt der eigentliche Brüller. Man kann sich da ja irgendwie so einen Termin aussuchen, zu dem man das haben will.
Was ist denn jetzt an diesem Kompass? Hier ist überhaupt kein Kompass. Hier ist nur ein Werbevideo.
Ja, nein. Dieser Kompass erklärt dir, wie du die andere Seite...
Aber warum erzählt man nicht die andere Seite, wie man sie benutzt, an der Stelle, wo ich sie benutze?
Ja, ja, genau.
Aber man muss jetzt erst mal erklären, wie man sich einloggt. Auf der einen Webseite erklären sie, wie man eine andere Webseite benutzt. Das soll man dann gleichzeitig machen. Ja, genau. Wieso erklären sie das nicht einfach auf der Seite, wo es ist?
Wer denkt sich sowas aus?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab so eine Ahnung.
Zwei verschiedene Teams. Zwei verschiedene Teams und Zuständigkeiten.
Und die einen dürfen nicht einfach irgendwie die Hilfe-Information da reinschreiben, weil das kriegen sie ja nicht in ihren QA-Prozess rein. Aber sie haben halt trotzdem den Auftrag, das irgendwie zu erklären.
Ich mach dafür dann eine eigene Webseite. Und was das geile ist, dann werden sie wahrscheinlich das so dokumentieren. Dann ändert sich die Software auf der anderen Seite.
Das passt alles gar nicht mehr zusammen. Bis hin zu, hast du es mal überprüft? Ob sie dann wirklich auch immer die richtige Terminologie benutzen? Ob sie nicht von, irgendwie auf einmal von Login sprechen? Immer Adresse sagen, aber eigentlich Mitbenutzernummer meinen oder sonst irgendwas?
Ja Moment, das Beste ist ja, also ich hab da ja so einen Termin ausgesucht. Irgendwie, das wäre jetzt Montag gewesen. Und hab aber irgendwie, ist dieser ganzen Zettelage, das nicht auf Anhieb gefunden, wo drin steht, zu welchem Termin sie das tatsächlich machen wollen. Das ist nämlich erst morgen.
Ich vergleiche das jetzt mal.
So, und das Beste, und das Beste ist, du kannst dich auch nicht anmelden in dem Kundencenter, bevor du nicht diese Leistung bekommst. Das heißt, du tippelst da deine komischen, was weiß ich, wie vielstelligen Zahlen da in diese Maske rein und er sagt immer nur Passwort, das ist falsch. Ja, weil der Bereitstellungstermin ist ja erst der 28. Also morgen. Und deswegen kannst du dich beim Kundencenter auch erst morgen anmelden. Ist doch logisch.
Obwohl da die einigen Informationen sind, die es dir einfach machen sollen, deinen Anschluss in Betrieb zu nehmen, oder wie? Bei mir war das nämlich sogar so, weil ich hab ja irgendwie verpeilt, meinen auslaufenden Anschluss irgendwie zu verlängern. Und dann haben sie mir das Teil einfach abgeschaltet. Und dann hab ich das irgendwie so relativ zeitnah durch Mithilfe noch von freundlichen Mitarbeitern so erkämpft, dass ich schnell wie möglich dann einen Wiederanschluss bekomme. Haben sie dann aber geschafft, mir, weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, aber sie haben es irgendwie geschafft, auf jeden Fall so Zettel zuzuschicken, wo dann irgendwie die alten und die neuen Zugangsdaten vertauscht waren. Und dann hab ich die ganze Zeit versucht, mich mit dem alten Account in diese Kundencenter einzulongen. Und das ging irgendwie alles nicht. Und zwar, das ist alles total disjunkt.
Und dann ist da natürlich noch ein QR-Code drauf. Ihre Zugangsdaten zum Scannen für die Einrichtung per DSL-Hilfe-App. Da sollten eigentlich die Alarmglocken schon klingeln. Man scannt also den Code, kann sich dann die DSL-Einrichtungshilfe-App runterladen. Und dann, das ist eigentlich ganz witzig, weil nämlich die App kennt dann diese ganzen dämlichen Zugangsdaten und kann die irgendwie direkt in den, wenn man so einen Speedport-Teil hat, da irgendwie eintragen. Aber, naja, bei der Fritzbox muss man es natürlich trotzdem irgendwie per Hand reintippeln. Na ja, mal sehen, was morgen passiert.
Woran ich übrigens komplett gescheitert bin, ist, man kriegt ja irgendwie mit diesem VDSL-Kram ja auch angeblich diesen Hotspot-Zugang irgendwie auch noch.
Ach guck mal, und ich hab noch eine DVD bekommen. Browser 7 der Telekom und ein Sicherheitspaket komplett. VLAN to go, Rechnung online. Und Virenschutze, ein Euro nur monatlich. Da ist nochmal ein Kundencenter auch noch mit drauf.
Man kann nicht genug Kundencenter haben.
Ein Online-Manager und Hilfe-Videos. Benutzerhandbücher für Speedport-Geräte und Media-Receiver. Bei Problemen bei der Einrichtung oder im Betrieb führen sie einen oder mehrere der folgenden Schritte aus. Erstens, Computer neu starten.
Du kannst dir wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht vorstellen, mit was für absurden, schwierigen Kunden, die das zu tun haben.
Die Partoo ihren Rechner nicht neu starten wollen.
Nee, die einfach auch wirklich so dermaßen wenig checken. Wir machen das natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen vom hohen Ross und wir verstehen das ja alles. Wir wollen nicht auf so einem subintellektuellen Level behandelt werden.
Aber das ist halt bei den meisten Leuten so. Diese vier Zahlen Mitbenutzernummer.
Das ist vollkommen kaputt, aber weißt du, wo das herkommt?
Nee.
Die Mitbenutzernummer? Also ich weiß überhaupt gar nicht, was die jetzt noch für eine Relevanz hat. Na die Mitbenutzernummer, das kommt von BTX.
BTX?
Ja, diese T-Online-Nummer ist der Nachfolger der BTX-Nummer. Und im BTX-System war die Mitbenutzernummer die Möglichkeit, halt andere Leute auf deinem Account mitnutzen lassen zu können. Das war ein BTX-Feature. Und aus BTX ist ja T-Online geworden. Und aus T-Online ist alles, was Internet... Und das ist sozusagen immer noch dieselbe Administrationssoftware, die das aus den 80er Jahren bis in die heutige Welt getragen hat. Und die sind einfach diese Nummerstruktur nie losgeworden. Frag mich mal, warum, also welchen Zweck diese Mitbenutzernummer noch hat. Also sie schreiben sie ja drauf, sie nennen sie auch noch so.
Ich weiß nicht, wer nutzt damit?
Also ich wüsste überhaupt nicht, wo ich eine Mitbenutzernummer aktiv zum Einsatz bringen soll. Aber sie präsentieren dir das. Ich meine, wenn man da jetzt als Berater hingeht und sagt, wenn die Telekom fragt so, oh Experte, berate uns und sag uns, was wir besser machen können, damit unsere Kunden uns besser verstehen. Dann wirst du doch erstmal ihnen diese Mitbenutzernummer irgendwie auf ein Stück Holz ausdrucken, rauslasern mit so einem 3D Device. So ein längliches Holzstück, machst du die Mitbenutzernummer drauf und dann haust du ihnen diese Mitbenutzernummer links und rechts um die Ohren so lange, bis es blutet. Und dann ist das Thema Mitbenutzernummer durch. Weil der andere Kram ist ja noch viel schlimmer.
Ja, da kommt der Techniker erst beim zweiten Termin und so. Da kommen gar keine Techniker, haben wir noch nie einen Techniker gesehen bei mir.
Der Techniker ist ja sowieso von der Telekom, da kannst du ja nichts machen, außer beim Kabelanschluss.
Da kommt doch gar keiner mehr. Du kriegst ein Paket, schließt an und bumm und dann geht's. Das war bei mir so.
Ja, das ist manchmal so. Aber das ist ganz häufig nicht so.
Ich hab ja gar keinen Router mitbestellt. Also, ich wollt diesen Speedpod-Scheiß ja gar nicht haben.
Also wenn du das nächste Mal an so einem Hotspot vorbei läufst, das ist jetzt auch nochmal eine Frage hier vielleicht an unsere Hörer, weil ich hab das irgendwie noch nicht geschnallt. Ich muss wahrscheinlich nochmal beim Support anrufen, dann werden sie es mir erzählen. Aber mir ist nicht gelungen, mit diesen Nummern, die es mir gegeben haben, mich irgendwie an so einen blöden Hotspot einzulaufen.
Also wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab, dann machen die aber da dieses komische Modell. Nur wenn dein eigener Router als Hotspot für alle anderen freigeschaltet ist, bekommst du auch den Zugang zu diesen Hotspots. So hab ich das verstanden aus der Doku. Aber dazu brauchst du halt auch einen von diesen Fliesenboden-Dingern.
Von diesen bekloppten Huawei-Teilen. Aber vielleicht haben sie mich ja oben aus dem Ohr gehauen.
Naja, wie auch immer. Also ich weiß nicht, bei DNSnet, die haben halt da irgendwie diese Kiste da an die Faser angeschlossen, Strom dran und dann ging's. Also irgendwie nicht mit irgendwas eingeben oder so.
Boah, hier gibt's ja auch irgendwie richtig exklusive, tolle Sachen, die man noch mitbenutzen kann. Die E-Mail, Mediencenter, E-Mail.
Welche Mitbenutzernummer hast du denn dann bei die E-Mail?
Keine Ahnung. Altersnachweis? Der Altersnachweis der Deutschen Telekom. Da kann man sich natürlich fragen, wozu braucht man das? Das kreut man noch ein bisschen weiter runter. Erotik-Lounge, sprickelnde Erwachsenenunterhaltung, Fotos, Filme, Clips, Abos, Live-Cams und viel mehr.
Ich weiß nicht.
Software-Load, über 30.000 Programme zum Runterladen. 30.000.
Ja, hier meint einer, du musst deinen WLAN für andere freigeben.
Ernsthaft? Na das ist ja wohl Verarscher.
Das hat doch schon bei diesen Foneiro-Leuten nicht funktioniert.
Ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob das nicht demnächst nochmal funktionieren würde. Werden sie Mitglied? Ich will nicht, nein.
Was brummelst du da in dich rein? Also das war mein Internet-Anschluss.
Hotspot, genau. Jetzt bin ich nämlich auf der Konfigurationsseite WLAN2GO und Hotspot. Und unten steht WLAN2GO.
Will ich nicht?
Wobei hier irgendwas steht mit ich bin bereits einmal angemeldet, was auch immer das jetzt wieder heißen soll. Oben gibt es dann aber auch noch Hotspot-Login-App. Zugangsdaten automatisch einrichten und so weiter. Mehr zur Hotspot-Login-App und was kommt dann? Na, die Seite, die sie aufgerufen haben, existiert nicht. Ich meine, hallo?
Ach guck mal mit diesen Phonenleuten, die dieses Phonero, Phonera Zeug gemacht haben, kooperieren die da. Ist ja interessant. Störerhaftung Anyone? Ja, keine Ahnung. Kann man die Störerhaftung an die Telekom weiterleiten, wenn irgendjemand beim WLAN2GO Scheiße auf meinem Hotspot macht? Gibt es Hotspots im Bingo?
Ich bin gerade total überrascht. Der erzählt mir jetzt gerade irgendwas von ich wäre angemeldet zum WLAN2GO. Gleich mal abmelden.
Also, also nächstes Mal mehr zu dem Thema. Ich hab so das Gefühl, dass es da dann auch immer noch was zu reden gibt.
Das ist geil. Jetzt klicke ich auf abmelden. Den Dialog muss ich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Beim Klick auf OK wird ihre Kündigung zunächst im Warenkorb vorgemerkt.
Ja, was ist eine Kündigung im Warenkorb? Musst du die dann auch bezahlen?
Um die Kündigung abzusenden, klicken sie bitte rechts oben auf Warenkorb anzeigen und wählen im nächsten Schritt Zahlungspflichtig bestellen.
Für sie entstehen dadurch keine weiteren Kosten. Vertrauen, made by Telekom.
Zahlungspflichtig bestellen.
Genau, keine weiteren Kosten. Nur Zahlungspflichtig bestellen.
Wer denkt sich so was aus?
Dass mit dem Zahlungspflichtig bestellen ist, aber allerdings tatsächlich das, was irgendwie von irgendwelchen Juristen mal kommuniziert wurde, was man seit...
Der Grund ist nur, sie haben nur dieses Shopping-Ding, um irgendwie ein Vorgang auszulösen, irgendwas zu konfirmen und jetzt präsentieren sie mir eine Rechnung mit irgendwie 0 Euro, 0 Euro einmalig, 0 Euro monatlich. Ihr Terminwunsch wird nach Eingang ihrer Bestellung von uns geprüft.
Einen verbindlichen Termin nennen wir ihn jedoch erst in der schriftlichen Auftragsbestätigung, die sie den kommenden Tagen per Post von uns erhalten. Leute!
Ah ja, genau, und der Versand der AGB-Unterlagen und der Bestellbestätigung erfolgt an meine E-Mail-Adresse blödenbeklopptenummer.at. Okay, ich geb noch eine andere an. Muss sie natürlich zweimal angeben, weil man kann sich ja vertippen, heutzutage, wo alles automatisch ausgefüllt wird. So, Aufträge absenden steht hier übrigens, nicht zahlungspflichtig bestellen. Das finde ich auch mal geil, dass man die ganze Beschreibung, den Hilfeseiten, dann mit der Realität einfach nichts zu tun hat. Jetzt gucke ich gerade auf so einen Spinner, da steht Daten werden geladen.
Am schönsten fand ich ja irgendwie diese App, die das mal mit Laden läuft übersetzt hatte. Ich dachte ja prima, dass euer Laden läuft.
Ihr Auftrag wurde entgegengenommen. Die Durchführung ihres Auftrags war erfolgreich.
Neu hinzugebuchte Produkte können sie sofort einsetzen. Nur Angst, die verbreiten nur Angst die ganze Zeit.
Das ist doch wirklich schlimm, oder? So, jetzt bin ich da raus, Gott sei Dank. Ich dachte schon, ich wäre hier irgendwas angemeldet. Gut, dann gibt es also keinen Hotspot für mich. Habe ich mich wieder bescheißen lassen. Na, Denis, bis durch, oder? Und Schluss machen. Ich kann ja, ich spiel dir ja dann noch ein Lied.
Genau. Ein schönes Lied.
Und so über die anderen Kram reden wir jetzt nicht mehr. Nee, ne?
Wir haben fast alles durch, glaube ich, oder?
Du weißt doch noch was über Programmieren und so.
Ja, ach nee, jetzt nicht mehr.
Nee, kein Bock.
Ja, ist jetzt auch nicht so spannend.
Nee, den Rest teste ich jetzt auch erstmal weiter. Wir sammeln jetzt erstmal wieder so ein bisschen Kram und dann sind wir wieder frisch am Start. Hoffentlich dann wieder mit anderen Mitstreitern. Also nicht, dass die Mitstreiter nicht passen würden, aber...
Wie haben wir das früher zu dritt geschafft?
Da hatten wir nicht so lange Sendungen.
Echt, ja?
Ja, wir haben da wirklich mal so eine anderthalb Stunde lang eine Sendung gemacht.
Echt? Einerthalb?
Ja, so fing das mal an. Also, soweit ich mich erinnere, schauen wir nochmal nach.
Da hatten wir wahrscheinlich noch Angst und haben überhaupt gar nicht uns getraut, ein bisschen vom Weg abzuweichen und haben wirklich nur straight irgendwie die Apple-Themen durchgezogen.
Ja, inzwischen ist das ja eher andersrum. Da haben wir Angst vor den Apple-Themen.
Ich nicht. Also Stunde 45 war das so am Anfang. Also immer unter zwei Stunden. Knapp an einer Zwei-Stunden-Marke gekratzt. Dann ging es mal in die Vollen hier. 2.43. Da war schon richtig was los. Ja, und dann riss es langsam ein. Also ist das. Dann sag ich einfach mal.
Sind ja auch schon wieder dreieinhalb Stunden, aber jetzt, oder?
Muss man sich jetzt nicht für schämen. Also jetzt nicht, was die Länge betrifft. Schön mit euch. Bis dann.
Bye bye.
Ihr sind die Eurocats mit Surfen Multimedia!